Ja, hier ist Chaosradio 50. Und das Thema heute lautet Rinder statt Schinder. Oder Rinder waren wir jetzt gerade deinen Einsatz gewesen. Der lautet das hier.
Dummheit in Schulen.
Genau.
Die weibliche Stimme, die ihr gehört habt, die nennt sich Lisa. Die erste männliche Stimme, die ihr gehört habt, nennt sich Andi. Und die nächste männliche Stimme, die ihr hören wird, nennt sich.
Und der, der das alles versucht zu moderieren, ist der gute Holger.
Genau.
Und die Musik kommt heute so gleich, wenn die Plattenspieler justiert sind und die Kinchkabel verlegt von DJ Otaku. Und bis dahin hören wir noch ein bisschen unseren Trailer an. Chaosradio 50, im Zeitalter, wo selbst Bestattungsinstitute einen URL haben.
www.verben.de Jetzt macht euch ja keine Werbung mehr.
Schöner Verben im Internet.
Genau, in der Bild-Zeitung auf Seite 1, Die Wallerts. Also das ist diese Familie, die das auf dem Zitadien-Bastanen steht. Das ist wirklich nicht mehr feierlich hier.
Psydismus beiseite, Freuspa.
Dafür gibt es eine Taste übrigens zum Aufholzbein.
Was das ILOVEYOU-Virus und die Greencard-Debatte verbindet. Also wir haben uns überlegt, dass die ganze Geschichte hat ja aber angefangen, dass ein frustrierter Schüler aus Manila ein Virus geschrieben hat. Er hat der ganzen Welt seine Liebe kundgetan, die Welt fand das gar nicht gut. Aber er hat eigentlich seine Beweggründe ganz klar in den Virus hineingeschrieben. Schon die erste Programm-Kurztheile enthielt einen Kommentar, I hate to go to school. Und dessen wollten wir uns mal annehmen. Es ist wohl offensichtlich, wir haben ein Problem im Bildungswesen. Wir haben auf der einen Seite frustrierte Schüler, die sich nicht sinnvoll beschäftigt fühlen und wohl auch nicht sinnvoll beschäftigt werden und so einen Unsinn schreiben. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir inkompetente Systembetreuer verantwortlich in Unternehmen, die Technologie einsetzen, die nicht mal Visual Basics-Grips standhalten und dann niederliegen.
Ja, aber es gibt hier jetzt einen Patch für Outlook, habe ich gelesen, der weist sämtliche Echsen ab.
Ist ganz toll. Und gestern kam dann aber noch eine neue Variante eines mutierenden Virus, der über die Visitenkarten-Funktion reinkam. Insofern war der Patch dann leider nur für Attachments-Grips und nicht für diese VCFs. Aber gut, das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Das interessante dabei ist, dass im Moment oder vor kurzem haben sich die Minister der G8 zusammengetroffen und wollten mal ein bisschen darüber reden, was man machen könnte, um das Netz sicher zu machen. Cyber-Cybercrime war das Thema von dem Treffen. Da haben sie überlegt, ob man nicht Hacker-Tools verbinden kann. Hacker-Tools sind Programme, womit die Skriptkitties die Rechner aufmachen können. Aber das wäre eigentlich ganz prima, weil dann würde als erstes Outlook und wahrscheinlich ganz Windows verboten werden. Outlook ist natürlich einfach das beste Programm, was dazu geeignet ist, um so eine Viren zu verbreiten, so eine E-Mail-Viren.
Na ja, gut. Also die Reihenfolge war etwas anders, aber ist das ohnehin nicht das Thema der Sendung? Nicht. Ne, also wir können da ein bisschen über aktuellen Kram plauschen. Es war halt so, dass diese G8-Sitzung über die Cybercrime-Convention, die war zufällig eine Woche nachdem der Virus da gefütet hat. Aber die Cybercrime-Convention selbst, wo die ganzen Kram drin stand, die gibt es schon seit Anfang des Jahres von den Amis geschrieben. Worüber wir eigentlich reden wollten, ist, was ist denn eigentlich los an den Schulen? Und es gab ja mal so ein tolles Projekt unter anderem, das hieß Schulen ans Netz. Und alle dachten, es wird gut und es war total... Ja, wie war das denn eigentlich?
Na es war komisch. Also es ist schon was passiert, aber irgendwie...
Na sag doch mal, du bist doch Schülerin. Seid ihr am Netz, ja?
Ja, wir sind am Netz und zwar sechs Stunden pro Tag, fünf Tage in der Woche. Und wenn es mehr wird, dann gibt's Hauer, habe ich so verstanden.
Ja, dazu muss man vielleicht mal kurz ausholen, woher kommt dieses Projekt Schulen ans Netz und warum. Das greift ja nicht mal bei allen Schulen, oder?
Naja, das Projekt Schulen ans Netz ist jetzt mittlerweile, also es hat sich als Institution, als Begriff jetzt irgendwie etabliert. Es gibt diesen Verein Schulen ans Netz, aber im Prinzip war das ja auch nur ein Anstoß. Und es ist ja nur schon etliche Jahre her, wo das irgendwie gekommen ist. Und es gibt jetzt in den einzelnen Bundesländern oder von den einzelnen Firmen, wie auch immer, irgendwie Initiativen, die jetzt die Sache anschieben wollten. Da gibt es zum Beispiel in Berlin das Projekt Kids Computer in die Schulen. Und das ist so eigentlich als eigenständige Sache gelaufen.
Zusammengefasst kann man aber sagen, es gibt eben nicht, also das Projekt Schulen als Netz, auch wenn es so heißt, heißt eben nicht, dass alle Schulen am Internet dranhängen, sondern das heißt, das ist damals im Bund-Länder-Streit, damals, als die Telekommunikation aufgeteilt wurde, so 95 rum, da gab es mal eine Idee und die Idee lautete, weil die Länder hatten eigentlich das Wegerecht, das heißt, die dürfen darüber entscheiden, wer die Kabel verlegt. Und dann hatte ein kluger Mensch, den in die Ohren geflüstert, warum macht ihr nicht einfach zur Bedingung für private Telekommunikationsfirmen, die auch bei euch Kabel verbuddeln wollen, dass alle öffentlichen Gebäude, zum Beispiel Schulen, öffentliche Bibliotheken und so fort, einfach umsonst angeschlossen werden.
Ist aber ein bisschen untergegangen, die Idee, ne?
Es ist nicht nur ein bisschen untergegangen, es ist komplett untergegangen, weil der Bund hat dann gesagt, ne, wir machen das ganz anders, wir schaffen eine zentrale Stelle und ihr bekommt Geld. Und Geld ist natürlich für die Länder, die auch monetäre Interesse haben und die angeblich immer pleite sind, wie auch immer, ist für die irgendwie ganz toll gewesen. Und dann haben sie gesagt, ach, öffentliche Anschlüsse, das ist irgendwie auch egal, eigentlich ist Geld viel besser. Und dann haben sie das Geld genommen. Und einer der Beweggründe war, weil diese Argumentation mit den öffentlichen Gebäuden in Schulen, die war ja nicht völlig von der Hand zu weisen, dass die irgendwie gesellschaftlich sinnvoll war. Die Telekom war dann in dieser Anhörung, in der Entscheidenden aufgetreten und hatte gesagt, nein, das müsst ihr überhaupt nicht machen, weil die Telekom, die deutsche Telekom, investiert 28 Millionen Mark. Also da wurde eine halbe Werbepredigt gehalten. Und wir bringen die deutschen Schulen an die Daten, auf die Autobahn und alle dachten, okay, das Problem ist erledigt. Und dann saß da noch so ein ketzerischer Typ vom Chaos Computer Club, der hat dann gesagt, ja, aber was heißt denn das, Schulen an die Datenautobahnen, was die Telekom da macht? Könnte es sein, dass sie da gerade kostenpflichtige T-Online-Anschlüsse denen andrehen, was nichts weiter heißt, als dass sie so eine Art mit Zehen sind, der erstmal Öllampen verschenkt, um dann den Sprit zu verkaufen. Und das fand die Telekom überhaupt nicht toll. Der hat sich dann aufgeregt und interessanterweise wurde das noch aus dem Protokoll gestrichen. Aber das ist eine lange Geschichte. Was dabei rausgekommen ist, ist, die Länder haben sich übers Ohr hauen lassen, sie haben kein Wiegerecht mehr. Das hat jetzt der Bund, dafür bekommen sie ein bisschen Geld. Und de facto sind die Schulen nicht wirklich am Netz, sondern haben teilweise kostenpflichtige T-Online-Anschlüsse, die dann eben zeitlich begrenzt kommen, weil die Schulen auch nicht so viel Geld haben. Und die andere Frage ist vor allem, haben sie denn überhaupt Computer? Wie viele Computer habt ihr?
Also wir sind ziemlich gut ausgestattet mit Computern durch diese Kitzeninstituten, wir haben jetzt 2 Computerräume mit je 12 Computern, glaube ich.
Für wie viele Schüler?
Unsere Schule hat, weiß nicht, 780 Schüler.
Und dann ist das gut ausgestattet, wenn ungefähr 25, 27 stehen? Das ist ziemlich gut ausgestattet. Das heißt, wenn ich das mal umrechne, auch Taschenrechner ansehen.
Das ist schon wichtig, dass viele Schulen mittlerweile Internet haben, oder zumindest einen ISDN-Anschluss und einen T-Online-Account, für den sie keine Rechnung bekommen oder nur theoretische Rechnungen bekommen. Das heißt also, sie müssen die Rechnungen nicht bezahlen. Aber sie haben dann einen Zugang. Woran es jetzt fehlt, sind zum einen natürlich PCs. Die Schulen, die einen besseren Zugang bekommen, haben dann immerhin einen Multimedia-PC bekommen. Wenn in der Schule jemand ein bisschen fit war, dann hat er diesen Multimedia-PC umgebaut zu einem schicken ISDN-Router, das nämlich auch das gesamte andere Schulnetz nutzen kann. Aber in Schulen, wo das nicht klappt, da steht jetzt ein PC irgendwo vielleicht im Lehrerzimmer oder im Technikraum. Und von den drei Leuten in der Schule, von den drei Lehrern, die da einen Schlüssel haben, die können da auch ab und zu mal rein. Und als Schüler muss man schon eine extreme Penetrans vorweisen, dass man da auch mal ran darf. Aber natürlich nur unter Aufsicht. Und der Lehrer steht immer dahin, weil man könnte ja auch sonst was da machen.
Das klingt außerordentlich ermutigend. Das klingt so, als würde da eine Jugend darauf wachsen, die voller Erfahrung, die unter spielerischen Bedingungen gesammelt sind.
Das war jetzt aber irgendwie das Negativbeispiel. Also bei uns läuft das schon relativ gut. Wir haben eben, das ist für Schüler nutzbar. Und da muss auch nicht immer ein Lehrer dahinter stehen. Das läuft über freiwillige Schüleraufsichten.
Und inwieweit haben die Lehrer da eine Ahnung, was ihr da macht?
So gut wie gar keine. Deshalb wird das auch auf Schüler irgendwie verteilt.
Und warum werdet ihr überhaupt beaufsichtigt?
Na, weil das teure Technik ist. Die gänzbösen Seiten werden schon gefiltert. Aber da kommen dann doch manchmal Sachen, wo man rumlaufen muss.
Ja, dazu habe ich noch was vor, die ich noch was zitieren.
Das ist irgendwie ein Konzept von einem Lehrer offenbar, einem Informatiklehrer, der sich mal Gedanken gemacht hat, wie so ein Internetzugang in der Schule aussehen kann. Und einer der Punkte, die er hier anspricht, lautet, das Internet bietet auch viele Bereiche, vor denen Jugendliche geschützt werden müssen. Ein abschottendes Tier nur schwer und unvollkommen möglich.
Wo hat das geschrieben?
Otto Schili?
Nein, den Namen will ich jetzt nicht nennen.
Das ist ein Dokument, das ist irgendwie, ich glaube, beim Aufräumen im Keller irgendwo aufgetaucht in einer Schule, einer Berliner Schule.
Das Internet ist ein Stück Hightech, das es jungen Menschen ermöglicht, Bombenbauanleitungen und Pomegranate nach Hause geliefert zu bekommen.
Genau das.
Und ja, ich meine, dann gibt es da noch irgendwie, also wir haben diese Sendung ein bisschen aufgeteilt, weil wir wollen nicht nur über die Katastrophe des Status Quo reden. Das ist eben sehr uneinheitlich an Schulen. Da wollen wir dann auch noch euch höher fragen, was ihr dazu zu berichten habt. Ausstattung gibt, Ausstattung heißt jetzt nicht nur reine Hardware und reine Netzzugänge, sondern auch eventuell Leute, die wissen, was da in diesen komischen Kisten mit den Tastaturen und den blinkenden Monitoren so drinnen passiert.
Genau, das wollen wir nämlich heute nicht machen, sondern wir wollen uns also nicht nur über Technik unterhalten. Wir hatten ja vor einer Weile schon mal eine Sendung zu dem Thema, die ist ja letztendlich doch ein bisschen in diese Linux-Windows-Diskussionen abgeglitten. Und wir wollen uns halt ein bisschen unterhalten über den Begriff Medienkompetenz. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen ein komisches Modewort geworden.
Hey, wir wollen das nicht über den Begriff unterhalten, wir wollen hier ein Konzept formulieren.
Genau, wir wollen das nämlich als Schuhfach haben.
Wir haben nämlich einen tollen Plan. Wir wollen nämlich die Welt retten. Und, wie war das noch schnell? Jetzt sollten wir noch mal Musik hören, der ist für alle.
Ich versuch dann noch mehr Musik zu hören.
Ich euch einen schö Tag bis zum nächsten Einleitung zum Thema, die Musik jetzt wirklich noch so laut. Wir haben hier noch Probleme mit den Kinsch-Kabeln, deswegen ist das alles noch ein bisschen wirr. Aber als Einleitung zum Thema dachten wir, bitten wir mal die Visa. Die Visa ist nämlich 16 und hat neulich mal ein Experiment gemacht, schon um 17. Und von diesem Experiments wollten wir sie bitten mal zu bewüsten. Was hast du ausprobiert?
Genau, das habe nicht ich ausprobiert. Das soll jetzt ein Erfahrungsbericht werden, wie das bei uns in der Schule aussah. Und das sieht schon im Vergleich, was ich so an anderen Schulen gesehen habe, relativ gut aus. Also mit Technik sind wir halbwegs gut ausgestattet. Und Internetanschluss ist noch gefiltert. Und SSH geht nicht raus, weil das alles über einen Proxy läuft. Also kein SSH. Selbst wenn irgendjemand wüsste, was das ist, könnte man das also nicht benutzen.
Geht das mit Windows überhaupt?
Das geht mit Windows auch, allerdings. Teradam, genau.
Und wie ist es mit den Lehrern?
Lehrer? Du meinst die, die da vorne stehen? Ja, Lehrer sind auch nochmal so eine komische Sache bei Computern. Weil viele Lehrer irgendwie sich das nicht aus der Hand nehmen lassen wollen. Die wollen dann aber, die wollen dann also immer mitreden und gefragt werden und mitentscheiden. Aber haben nicht wirklich Durchblick, was dann zu entscheiden ist. Also das läuft dann effektiv so.
Hältst du den Lehrer für lärmfähig? Bedingt. Na dann beschreib mal, wie läuft denn das so ab?
Das läuft so ab, dass es zum Beispiel... Ach genau, ich hatte versucht, den Lehrern Internet beizubringen. Genau. Das war der Bericht, den wir hören wollten. Das nannte sich Internetentführung für Lehrer und das ging auch ein paar Mal gut.
Was heißt ein paar Mal?
Ja so zwei oder drei Mal kamen dann so vier, fünf Lehrer.
Was heißt das? Also extra Termin nachmittags?
Ja nachmittags, natürlich. Nachmittags, vormittags sitze ich im Unterricht. Da kann ich kein Internetentführung. Im Computerkabinett. Genau. Dann habe ich ihnen erklärt, wie man so praktisch die Internetverbindung aufbaut. Das ist ja wichtig, wenn man mit Schülern ins Internetkabinett will. Und dann musste ich feststellen, dass ich ihnen erstmal beibringen sollte, was ein Browser ist und wie man Hundersprogramme benutzt teilweise.
So Maus und Anschalter wussten sie gerade noch, oder?
Ja, das wussten sie noch, genau. Allerdings gibt es da bei uns auch ein Problem, man muss da nämlich immer einen Schalter umlegen, um den Strom anzuschalten. Das hat schon Lehrer zur Verzweiflung getrieben. Nach 2-3 Mal saß ich dann nachmittags da und bin nach einer halben Stunde in den Gang, weil niemand gekommen ist und habe dann gesagt...
Das heißt, die Lehrer wussten alles?
Na ja, genau so. Offensichtlich. Offensichtlich wussten sie ja alles.
Hast du denn deinen Lehrern sozusagen nach Beendigung dieses Kurses zentruliert gegeben?
Nein, so weit ist das ja gar nicht gekommen.
Oder wenigstens die ein oder andere Kopfmote.
Es war ja noch nicht zu Ende. Also wir hatten gerade irgendwie... Na ja, wir hatten glaube ich noch nie mal bei Suchmaschinen angefangen.
Das heißt, Desinteresse?
Na, ich weiß nicht, ob es nur Desinteresse ist. Also jetzt immer auf die Lehrer zu bashen, ist vielleicht nicht ganz das wahre, weil die ja schließlich auch nebenbei noch einen Beruf haben.
Ja, aber wenn du aus denen nicht gefeuert werden kannst, wenn du bestimmte Dinge nicht kannst...
Na, die Frage ist halt die, ich meine, jetzt mal kurz zusammengefasst, du hast, dein Lehrern versucht sozusagen, was beizubringen.
Internetbatch bringen, ja. Und ganz davon abgesehen, dass das schwierig ist, weil die meisten ja auch schon etwas älter sind.
War dann anstrengend dich da wenigstens Begeisterung? Oder wie war denn das jetzt? Wie wurde das denn erstmal grundsätzlich aufgenommen?
Das wurde so aufgenommen, dass sie eigentlich relativ begeistert waren. Also ja, und das wollte ich ja schon immer mal wissen. Und da klären wir uns das mal.
Was waren das für Lehrer? War das durch alle Fächer durch? Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass ein Deutschlehrer zum Beispiel war. Na ja, Internet, ganz gut, aber eigentlich würde ich das im Unterricht auch gar nicht machen.
Wozu auch?
Doch, das war durch alle Fächer. Also Chemie, Deutsch, was war noch? Geschichte, Informatik, Physik, alles Mögliche.
Und haben die denn dir irgendwie eine Erklärung gegeben, warum sie nicht mehr kommen?
Nein, natürlich nicht, sie sind mir keine Rechenschaft schuldig.
Wieso? Wenn du da ein Angebot machst und die sagen, sie kommen, ich meine, die werden doch auch irgendwann mal gesagt haben, ja, finden wird irgendwie. Und dann sind sie einfach nicht mehr gekommen.
Ja.
Was würde ein Lehrer sagen, wenn die Schüler irgendwie einen Kurs wählen, was weiß ich, einen Physikkurs oder so, in den etwas höheren Klassen, kann man da ja so Kurse wählen, dann gehen sie zweimal hin und dann sagen sie, ich will nicht mehr. Ich meine, wie würden Lehrer darauf reagieren?
Keine Ahnung, also manche würden sagen, was soll das, und andere würden sagen, es ist mir doch egal, es ist ja deine Schulbildung.
Und das heißt, du sagst jetzt auch, es ist mir doch egal, wenn meine blöden Lehrer das nicht lernen wollen, dann ist es ein integrieren Bildungsproblem?
Das ist ja, hör mal, auch Adi, das sind ja nicht nur die blöden Lehrer, sondern die haben tatsächlich auch was zu tun hin und wieder. Und jetzt aufgrund der Tatsache, dass sie nochmal eine Stunde draufkriegen, ohne zusätzliche Bezahlung natürlich, und eine Stunde Unterricht heißt auch gleichzeitig eine Stunde mehr Vorbereitung, eine Stunde mehr Testkontrollieren und so weiter.
Einspruch!
Eine Ex-Freundin von mir ist Lehrerin und das ist nicht wahr, wenn die eine Stunde länger unterrichtet, dann heißt das nicht automatisch eine Stunde mehr Vorbereitung, eine Stunde mehr Hausaufgaben. Das ist TINES.
Das wollte es im Endeffekt eigentlich heißen.
Das halte ich wirklich für Jammerreif.
Moment, Moment, aber wir reden jetzt noch gar nicht von einem zusätzlichen Schulfahrt, sondern wir reden jetzt erstmal davon, dass sie nachmittags nochmal eine Stunde hingehen, da müssen sie sich ja überhaupt nicht vorbereiten, sondern da können sie einfach hingehen und dann können sie sich was beibringen lassen.
Das war doch der Punkt unten, oder ist ja auch nicht dafür bezahlt, oder?
Ja, oder die können nicht lassen, so einen Mist gemacht haben.
Also ich denke, es wäre auf jeden Fall ein klügerer Zug gewesen, anstatt den Lehrern irgendwie eine Stunde mehr Arbeit irgendwie aufzubürden, lieber zu sagen, okay Leute, ihr müsst da für eine Stunde die Woche eine Fortbildung machen, und zwar irgendwie im Bereich neue Medien fertig.
Ja, da gibt es denn sowas? Ich weiß, es gibt ein Institut für Lehrerfortbildung.
Genau, es gibt das BEL in Berlin, das ist das Berliner Institut für Lehrerbildung, die bieten sowas an, es gibt die Landesbildstelle in Berlin, die bieten sowas an, und es gibt mittlerweile auch noch von der, ich glaube, der Berliner Bank, die BB Data Jungs irgendwie, und die Telekom bieten auch Fortbildungen an für Lehrer. Gut, kann man sehen, wie man will, aber es gibt diese Fortbildung theoretisch. Der Andrang ist schon groß, also das ist auch nicht so, dass die Lehrer da ganz irgendwie ohne Interesse sind, aber das reicht alles noch nicht weit, und das Problem ist, dass sie mit den technischen Grundlagen erst mal anfangen. Das heißt also, bis die Lehrer so weit sind, wie sag ich mal, wie jetzt, also das ist für uns einfach relativ normal oder völlig normal, irgendwie mit dem Netz zu arbeiten, E-Mails zu verschicken und alles, und irgendwie wir verschicken einfach aus unserem reinen Selbstverständnis raus, sage ich mal, keine HTML-Mails und so eine Sache, bis sowas einfach irgendwie erst mal sitzt, bis sowas Selbstverständlichkeit, das werden dann noch Jahre ins Land gehen bei den Lehrern. Da können ja so wirklich etliche Jahre noch zu irgendwelchen Schulungen und Vorstellungen gehen, also das fehlt einfach ganz, ganz viel.
Das ist ein schönes Beispiel mit den HTML-Mails. Du glaubst, das wird doch irgendwann mal aufhören?
Er glaubt an das gute Menschlichste.
Also das bringst du dir nicht mehr bei, denke ich wirklich.
Naja, das wäre ja auch gar nicht so dramatisch, wenn sie stattdessen einfach mal Suchmaschinen benutzen könnten. Dann würde ich diese HTML-Mails auch nehmen.
Ja, aber die Frage, die ich trotzdem nochmal an dich habe, Lisa, ich meine, wenn du sowas jetzt machst, du nimmst jetzt die Lehrer ein bisschen im Schutz. Ich habe ja auch nicht gesagt, dass sie doof sind. Ich habe nur die Frage gestellt, warum sind sie nicht mehr gekommen? Haben sie dir denn überhaupt nichts gesagt? Haben sie gesagt, das ist uns jetzt zu viel Stress oder wir haben nicht die Zeit, wir müssen hunderte von Klassenarbeiten korrigieren?
Also so richtig gesagt hat da keiner was. Die sind eben einfach nicht mehr gekommen. Und das war es soweit.
Also mangels Interesseprojekt eingestellt oder wie hast du das gesagt?
Mangels Enthusiasmus, würde ich einfach mal sagen. Also sie sind ja eigentlich nicht gezwungen dazu. Sie können nicht ihren Job verlieren und es ist eigentlich auch nicht definiert, ihre Aufgabe aus ihrem Selbstverständnis heraus.
Also das heißt, dass sozusagen weder Enthusiasmus, noch Engagement an der Stelle von dir auch erwartet werden.
Naja, ich glaube mal es wäre schön, aber voraussetzung kann man es eigentlich nicht.
Aber warum müssen eigentlich Lehrer, warum sollen sich Lehrer mit dem Internet auskennen? Also alle Lehrer, sage ich mal.
Also dass es halt Lehrer geben soll, die sich damit auskennen. Ja, aus der einfachen Tatsache heraus, dass alleine schon die Verfügbarkeit des Mediums Internet und des Mediums Computer als Werkzeug, als Schreibwerkzeug, als Arbeitswerkzeug, als Denkwerkzeug, als Datenbankwerkzeug und so weiter und so fort ist doch durch alle Professionen irgendwie ist normal ein Werkzeug. Und wie früher hat man da glaube ich mit so Papier und so Stiften gemalt und so.
Gut, aber willst du wirklich, dass die Leute irgendwie ihren Deutsch aufsetzen und Computer schreiben?
Also ich muss gestehen, ich habe das damals auch gemacht. Ich hatte immer einen Laptop mit und ich will nicht sagen, dass ich damit nicht nur Stress hatte, aber die waren doch relativ dankbar, dass ich meine Aufsätze irgendwie ausgedruckt habe, weil meine Handschrift, gut, okay, die hat halt ein bisschen darunter gelitten, dass ich irgendwie schon ein bisschen jünger an die Tessentur geraten bin.
Das kann ich bestätigen.
Und ja, das ergibt gerüchteweise auch anderen so. Und die Frage ist, ist das ein Verbrechen irgendwie? Ich meine, gut, kann das damit prallen, ich war relativ gut im Deutsch, aber wie gesagt, Handschrift ist nicht so mein Ding.
Na, ich sehe da ein Problem, wenn die Technik, das heißt also das Arbeiten mit der Technik, die eigentlichen Inhalte auch verdrängt. Das heißt also, wenn es erstmal darum geht, wenn die Leute im deutschen Unterricht wirklich erstmal eine halbe Stunde brauchen, bis sie ihr Wort soweit haben, dass sie damit arbeiten können.
Das ist ein anderes Thema. Deswegen werden wir das auch jetzt im Laufe der Sendung ein bisschen aufteilen. Vielleicht nach dem Fritz-Kurz-Info gibt es erstmal eine kleine Runde über Technikkompetenz, aber wir wollen das auch abtrennen, von dem was wir eigentlich wollen.
Leider Gottes, weil wir ein kleines technisches Problem haben mit dem Mono. Ich hoffe, ihr verzeiht mir das und ich hoffe, ihr verzeiht mir auch, dass ich diesen Musikfluss kurz unterbreche. Aber wir haben Dinge zu vermelden. Es ist nämlich so ziemlich 22 Uhr, na gut 33.
Kompromiss. Autohersteller in der EU sollen ab 2007 alle Altfahrzeuge umsonst entsorgen. Darauf einigten sich EU-Ministerrat und Europäisches Parlament in Brüssel. Ursprünglich sollte die Altautorichtlinie bereits ein Jahr früher in Kraft treten. Dafür bleibt es jedoch bei der vollen Kostenübernahme durch die Produzenten. Ermittlungen. Rund einen Monat nach dem Anschlag auf die Erfurter Synagoge hat der Generalbundesanwalt Anklage gegen drei 17-jährige Rechtsextreme aus Thüringen wegen versuchter schwerer Brandstiftung erhoben. Sie gelten als mutmaßliche Urheber des Anschlags, der bundesweit für Empörung gesorgt hatte. Beschluss. Das Bundeskabinett hat den Einsatz von deutschen Soldaten im Kosovo verlängert. Ursprünglich sollte die zunächst auf ein Jahr begrenzte Bundeswehrmission am 11. Juni beendet werden. Studentendemo. Mehr als 3000 Menschen haben in der serbischen Stadt Nisch gegen den jugoslawischen Präsidenten Milošević protestiert. Sie forderten die Regierung auf, ihre Repressionen gegen Oppositionsanhänger und unabhängige Medien einzustellen.
Sport.
Fußball. Real Matriz hat offensichtlich die Champions League gewonnen. Ich kann im Moment noch nicht sagen, ob das Spiel beendet ist. Gut, also auf jeden Fall stand es vor dem Beginn der Nachrichten zwischen Real Matriz und FC Valencia 3 zu 0 für Real. Und deswegen gehe ich mal davon aus, dass sie die Champions League gewonnen haben. Nachts mest trocken 14 bis 11 Grad. Morgen dann Regenschauer 18 bis 24 Grad. B5 von Naunen Richtung Berlin im Bereich der Ausfahrt Berlin-Spannau. Kommt es zur zeitweiligen Sperrung der B5 aufgrund einer Durchfahrt mehrerer Schwerlasttransporte. Nährt euch im Bereich vorsichtig und passt auf, es könnte Stau geben.
22 Uhr gleich 35 Minuten. Das war ein Kurzinform mit Irina Gaborfsky. Vielen Dank.
The Festival formerly known as Pop 2000.
Köche?
Kommt doch.
Samstag, 3.
Juni im Waschhaus Potsdam.
Mit Live-Acts wie Gonzales, Lato, Nio Angin, Melody und Miles. Dazu jede Menge DJs. Stereo Deluxe. 90 60 90.
Und viele mehr.
Ihr könnt Bilder gucken, Platten kaufen, Leuten beim Lesen zu hören.
Wann kommt denn das mit den Köchen?
Und mit Hiro und Tito japanische Nudelsuppen essen.
Horb am Regen.
Samstag, 3. Juni in Warschau, Potsdam. Präsentiert von...
Musik ist immer noch von Otaku und wir melden uns gleich.
Wir haben uns überlegt, es gibt noch eine spannende Frage, die hier im Seitengespräch ausgekommen ist und die lautet, was ist eigentlich mit den Lehrern los? Und das wollte ich jetzt noch mal auf der Lisa herausführen. Wie ist denn das, wenn du als Schülerin jetzt möglicherweise sogar berechtigterweise damit was ankommst, wo eben das mal andersrum läuft, wo die was lernen müssen?
Ja, bei diesen Internet-Einführungen war ich echt überrascht, weil die Lehrer da wirklich kooperativ und freundlich und wissbegierig waren, aber wenn das um andere Sachen geht, speziell wenn ich mich mit meinen Informatik-Lehrern auseinandersetze, sieht das irgendwie ganz anders aus, weil die halt immer mitreden wollen und ihre, naja, Autoritätsstellung nicht aufgeben wollen und sich wahnsinnig angepisst fühlen. Das war zum Beispiel so, dass ein Freund von mir, der sich da vor ein paar Jahren relativ viel engagiert hat, sagt uns, ich mach das nicht mehr, ihr könnt mich alle, wenn ich da erst noch alle überzeugen muss, dass das gut ist, dann kann ich mir das sparen, dann mach ich Sachen, die mir Spaß machen oder mich weiterbringen, ist mir dann egal, was hier in der Schule passiert, weil das eben so ging. Wir hatten eine tolle Idee und waren voller Taten rang und gingen zu unserem Informatik-Lehrer und der meinte. Müssen wir da nicht, aber... Und dann kamen erst mal irgendwelche komischen Argumente und letztendlich waren wir völlig entmutigt. Und er sagte dann zwar, ja, mach das mal, aber Tenor war dann doch eigentlich, na ja, und brauchen wir das und das wollen wir doch gar nicht.
War das jetzt eher so bei diesem einen Fall oder würde es dir generell sein, dass Lehrer sich merkwürdig verhalten, wenn Schüler ankommen und ihnen was versuchen beizubringen?
Das tun sie eigentlich nur, wenn sie glauben, dass sie schon ein bisschen Ahnung haben. Also wenn sie von vornherein wissen und sagen, dass sie genau gar keine Ahnung haben, so wie das bei dieser Intenenteinführung der Fall war, dann sind sie eigentlich sehr kooperativ, aber speziell wenn es um die Fachbereichsleiter Informatik geht, das ist irgendwie ein weitverbreitetes Phänomen, habe ich so festgestellt, dann wird es ziemlich haarig.
Ja stimmt, weil die haben ja auch eine sozusagen Autoritätsstellung wahrscheinlich wegen über den anderen Lehrern. Da holst du gerade einen Kuhruf vom Socke.
Genau, das würde man damit versuchen.
Machen Informatiklehrer, also bei uns war das früher so, dass Informatiklehrer sich erstmal wochenlang die Finger an der Tafel wundgeschrieben haben, bevor sie einen überhaupt mal ins Gerät gelassen haben, ist das immer noch, oder haben die da jetzt ein bisschen dazugelernt?
Oder überhaupt mal?
Ähnliches ist es eigentlich immer noch, aber das ist ja gar nicht so schlimm.
Wie fand das damals grauenhaft?
Ich finde, Informatik ist eigentlich kein Fach, wo man zwangsläufig am Computer sitzt. Aber gut, das ist was anderes.
Ich habe auch schon auf einem Papier meine Programme geschrieben.
Aber du sitzt da in der Schule, bist jung und sagst, Informatik ist das, was ich lerne, wie Computer gehen.
Das ist eben nicht Informatik, sondern das hat eigentlich mit Informatik kaum was zu tun.
Genau.
Ja, ich meine gut, okay, das heißt, wir gehen also davon aus, dass, wenn wir von den Informatik-Lehrern mal nicht absehen, Lehrer durchaus in der Lage wären, sich auch mit neuer Materie, weil gerichteweise entwickelt sich die Welt ja weiter und auch Technologien entwickeln sich weiter und so fort. Also glaubst du, dass man die auch updaten könnte?
Ja, Lehrer durchaus updaten, denke ich schon.
Also auch patchfähig.
Allerdings ist da natürlich die Bereitschaft untereinander, diese Peer-Group-Geschichte, nicht so gut funktioniert, weil das eben alle schon ältere Lehrer sind.
Was heißt das, dass sie nicht untereinander kooperativ miteinander umgehen?
Nein, das heißt eigentlich, dass sie sich wenig selber beibringen. Das funktioniert ja unter den Fachbereichslehrern so, dass sie sich gegenseitig was beibringen. Bei Computern und Internet ist das eben anders, weil die Lehrer schon alle relativ alt sind. Na ja, Belegschaft ist so durchschnittlich 50 plus und die Jüngsten haben zwei jüngere Lehrer, die sind Mitte 30 oder so.
Sind die denn, ich sag mal so, learning by doing fähig, also setzen die sich auch hin und experimentieren rum oder wollen die dann klare Handlungsanweisungen, wo muss ich jetzt draufklicken, damit das Fenster da das macht?
Ja, unterschiedlich. Die Jüngstenlehre muss das glaube ich, die setze ich auch selber hin und das ist auch die, die am intensivsten im Unterricht mit ihren Schülern Internet nutzt und die Älteren wollen lieber an die Hand genommen werden, also die mit denen ich da zu tun hatte.
Also die wollen dann irgendwie, dass man ihnen die Maus führt, oder?
Ja, also da fühlen sich dann relativ sicher bei ihnen.
Und wie verhalten die sich, wenn man ihnen irgendwie eine Kommandozeile vorsetzt oder so?
Nein, das habe ich noch nicht ausprobieren, das ist so verrückt.
Wenn es Herzinfarkte, Krankenwagenbedarf und irgendwie holte Adrenalinspritzen könnte passieren.
Ja, vermutlich würden sie denken, der Computer ist kaputt, aber na gut.
Aber die wissen wohl, wofür die Rollentaste ist, was ich ja nicht wusste.
Ja, gut, ich meine die Frage ist ja ein bisschen tatsächlich, also wenn man jetzt dieses Thema Medienkompetenz angibt, mir haben wir gesagt, wir wollen es ein bisschen trennen von Technikkompetenz, weil das eine ist, dass eigentlich jeder heute, also mit jeder meinen wir auch jeder Lehrer und jede Lehrerin zumindest grob wissen sollte, wie irgendwie ein Computer funktioniert, auch wie das Internet funktioniert, irgendwie was ESDN ist und so weiter und so fort. Also dass wir eben keine Angst davor haben und auch irgendwie wissen, wie man eine blöde Text verarbeitet.
Und was noch besser ist, sich keinen Quatsch aufschwatzen lassen.
Genau, indem man sich zumindest ein bisschen, auch der Marketingmechanismen, die in diesem Mediengeschehen wirken, bewusst ist. Aber das ist ja nur die eine Voraussetzung, die andere ist sozusagen, und deswegen finde ich die Frage so wichtig, wenn wir jetzt tatsächlich rangehen, und das machen wir jetzt gleich, und sagen, wir wollen einen neuen Schulfahrer, und das heißt Medienkompetent und bestellen uns da das und das vor. Da hat man ja auch eine Grundvoraussetzung, ist ja das Mindset sozusagen, das Bewusstsein, das man antritt, der Lehrer. Und die Frage, die ich mir stellen kann, die sagt, die sind über 50, also...
Also das sollten eigentlich extra...
Packungsfrische Lehrer rüber, Herr, haben wir nicht irgendwie Bildungs...
Wobei wir bei den Lehrern eigentlich eine ganz gute Voraussetzung haben, weil viele von den Lehrern, die jetzt noch aktiv sind, haben ja auch irgendwie ein bisschen in den 68ern noch zu Ende studiert, zumindestens, und haben deswegen vermutlich noch so ein bisschen einen sehr kritischen Ansatz, Denkansatz teilweise.
Du meinst, die wollen irgendwie... Computer sind erstmal das Grundübel?
Nee, gar nicht mal. Also gerade wenn es darum geht, jetzt so zu Medien zu kritisieren und irgendwie Werbung ist schlecht und kommerzielle Sachen sind irgendwie bäh und sowas, so wie es damals beim Fernsehen war. Beim Fernsehen waren wir auch sehr, sehr kritisch. Und das, was damals beim Fernsehen, also Fernsehen...
Du meinst, du bist so Einzug des Privatfernsehens, oder?
Genau, da wurde ja auch sehr viel gewertet. Und ich glaub, dass damals, also das hab ich zumindest mitgekriegt in meiner Schulzeit, was bei uns so gelaufen ist, wie Fernsehen gemacht wird, wie Werbung funktioniert, da war ich eigentlich im Nachhinein ganz glücklich mit. Und ich glaub, dass die Message, die da bei den Lehrern rübergekommen ist, irgendwie von der Grundhaltung eher kritisch war. Und ich glaub, dass das eigentlich ein ganz guter Grundansatz ist, um irgendwie auch da jetzt einzusteigen, dass natürlich die Technik mittlerweile viel komplizierter geworden ist und dass alles viel, viel größer und breiter und mächtiger geworden ist, ist natürlich ein anderes Problem.
Ja, aber ich meine, gut, ich frag dich jetzt mal nicht, wie alt du bist und wann du das genossen hast. Ich hab sowas nicht genossen, aber ich kann dir zumindest sagen, meine Mutter ist Vorschullehrerin und die hat eine Zeit lang einfach mit dem Problem zu kämpfen gehabt, dass es da dieses Power Rangers gab. Das ist irgendwie eine, keine Ahnung, das ist irgendwas im Fernsehen. Das hat irgendwie wohl mit Gewalt und Comicfiguren zu tun. Und das Problem ist halt, dass egal, ob es im Fernsehen um Mitternacht um 18 Uhr oder nachts um 3 kommt, irgendwie die Vorschultvideos, die so 6 sind so, die spielen das dann morgens um 8 irgendwie nach. Und Power Rangers war wohl so das anstrengendste, was es da je gab, von den Auswirkungen her betrachtet. Die haben sich dann irgendwie gegenseitig quer durch die Flüge geschleift und sich dabei die Köpfe eingehauen. Also das muss wohl irgendwie ganz cool sein, da.
Ich habe aber gar nicht früh genug gelernt, was es bedeutet, Schmerzen zu erzahlen.
Und sie hat mir dann, das fand ich relativ amüsant berichtet, das ist dann am Institut für Lehrer, Fortbildung, das Ganze ist in Hamburg. Da gab es dann irgendwie mehr oder weniger eine Veranstaltung. Also es war wohl an mehreren Schulen bei dieses Phänomen aufgetreten.
Und die Lehrer wurden zwangsläufig irgendwie die Power Rangers zu gucken, damit die dann wissen, was da überhaupt passiert wäre.
Ja, so ungefähr, beziehungsweise es gab dann zwei Fraktionen, die einen haben gesagt, wir müssen das irgendwie verbieten. Das ist die kritische Fraktion sozusagen, die du glaube ich gerade erwähnt hast. Die alten 68er, wenn die nämlich auf Privatfernsehprodukte schließen, dann sagen die irgendwie, wollen wir das nicht verbieten und kontrollieren das überhaupt. Und dann gab es noch einen Vorstoß, der wohl aber gleich niedergeschrien wurde. Und das war ein Experiment, das lautete Power Rangers, Pädagogik. So wie können wir uns die Medienprodukte irgendwie zu Nutzen machen? Ja genau, und dabei noch Wertvorstellungen vermitteln oder so. Aber wie gesagt, das hat sich wohl aufgrund der Proteste der von dir gerade erwähnten kritischen Leverfraktion nicht...
Aber das ist doch bestimmt mal ein spannendes Experiment. Die Leute schleifen sich da gegenseitig über den Flügel, der da dran sitzt. Was hast du dabei empfunden?
Da gab es dann auch noch die Sache mit der Verantwortung und so.
Bevor wir jetzt ganz abschweifen, ich mach mal ne kleine Musik, dann können wir uns wieder sammeln, oder?
Ja, ich find das eigentlich aber gut in Ordnung. Ja, mach mal, mach mal, Lade. So, wir haben uns überlegt, wir würden natürlich jetzt auch schon die ersten Hörer reinheben, wenn sie dann vielleicht, also ein paar Erfahrungsberichte aus anderen Schulen würden uns auch interessieren und auch vielleicht hören wir uns ja über Lehrer zu, keine Ahnung, auch über sozusagen deren Horizont würden wir natürlich gerne was erfahren, wie weit da dann tatsächlich vielleicht zeitliche, vielleicht konzeptionelle, vielleicht gehirnakrobatische Probleme bestehen, sich diesem Thema zu nähern.
Ich lasse mich gerade mal die Nummer ansagen, wenn es auf geht.
Die Krips-Hotline ist geschaltet.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Ah ja Holger, sollten wir jetzt noch deine aktuelle Funknummer überfunkieren?
Spannend wäre es auch, wenn Menschenlehrer anrufen, dann wissen wir vielleicht auch mal ganz gern, was es gerade so an aktuellen Fortbildungsangeboten gibt. Ob es welche gibt, es gibt auf jeden Fall welche, aber wie das ist, ob die irgendwie überbelegt sind oder ob die Leute da irgendwie mit Kaffee und Kuchen empfangen werden, weil irgendwie keiner kommt oder wieder die Situation gerade ist. Das fände ich mal ganz spannend.
So, jetzt drehen wir mal über das erste Kapitel. Das erste Kapitel haben wir ja Technikkompetenz genannt. Also die Idee bestand daran, wenn wir sagen, wir wollen eigentlich ab der fünften Klasse ein Schulfach, das heißt Medienkompetenz, aber dazu muss man natürlich zunächst einmal Grundlagen vermitteln. Und da wir hier nicht nur mit Medienkompetenz jetzt Computer oder Internetkompetenz meinen, sondern eben tatsächlich Medien im Sinne von fahr man ruhig mit der Zeitung an und dann waren da noch diese komischen Apparate, die man leider nur zugucken kann und wo man nicht wirklich interagieren kann.
Kann man nicht klippen.
Kann man nicht.
Na doch.
Wunderbares digitales Medium.
Dann waren da noch diese ganz bekrusteten Strukturen. Ich glaube, das hieß Radio damals. Da waren so irgendwie Leute, haben geredet und andere mussten zuhören, aber sie durften anrufen.
Es ist dieses veraltete analoge Konzept. Apropos, ich habe ein Stichwort gekriegt.
Hast du da wieder so eine Taste?
Ich habe hier so eine Taste und unter der wohnt Dustin. Hallo, Dustin.
Ich wollte über meine eigene Schule berichten.
Ja, na ja, das wollen wir hören.
Also erstmal zur technischen Ausstattung. Wir haben 18 PCs und eine Telefonleitung.
Auf wie viele Schüler?
Im Moment, also wir sind Neugimnasen. Wir haben jetzt acht Klassen, 22 Schüler. Also noch nicht so viel. Und in der siebten Klasse gibt es so einen Pflichtfach, das heißt Informatik. Das ist ja anspruchsvoll. Wir schreiben einen Brief mit Word 97.
Das ist Informatik bei euch?
Ja, so in der Form ungefähr. Harry Hobbs hüpft über die Wiese. Wir schreiben einen Brief mit Word 97. Dann hatte ich mit dem Lehrer, der ist auch unser Direktor, der denkt, er ist voll kompetent und so. Da klickt er erst mal drei Stunden. Jetzt klickt ihr mit eurer Maus. Ach so, übrigens nicht wundern, dass wenn ihr eure Hand bewegt, der Zeiger auf dem Bildschirm sich bewegt usw. Auf der Teilspeichern unter. Klickt bloß nicht das X an, sonst schließt sich das Fenster. Also wirklich sehr, sehr anspruchsvoll.
Aber wie ist es mit den anderen? Also bei dir klingt es ja jetzt so, als wenn das für dich absoluter Quatsch ist. Und du wirst es natürlich ganz genau, dass du nicht irgendwie auf X klicken darfst. Aber wie ist es mit den anderen Leuten bei dir im Kurs oder in der Klasse?
Na wir haben in der Schule so acht, neun Leute, die Ahnung haben von PCs. Und der sagt so nach dem Motto, irgendwie passt das Internet nicht im Monitor.
Wird denn da auch ein bisschen erzählt, wie ein Computer funktioniert? Oder ist es tatsächlich nur irgendwie mit einer Maus Windhoff bedient?
Na also, ganz zu Anfang, als der Artunterricht angefangen hat, hatten wir überhaupt erst mal noch keine Computer. Da haben wir uns dann so Sachen gezeigt, wie so eine Monsterfestplatte aus 3.6.8. Das ist eine Festplatte. Und dann so, ui, was sind denn die silbernen Punkte da rauf? Also, es ist wirklich ziemlich extrem.
Aber konnten auf die Frage die Lehrer sinnvolle Antworten geben?
Wie bitte?
Konnten die Lehrer auf die Frage, was diese silbernen Punkte da in diesem komischen Apparat sind, sinnvolle Antworten geben?
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Eigentlich mehr so, ja, das ist eine Festplatte, das ist ein Speichermedium, fertig.
Also wissen sie es auch nicht, oder?
Aber wissen es gibt es an eurer Schule noch ITG? ITG, Informationstechnische Grundbildung. Das ist eigentlich das, wo genau das, was du jetzt berichtet hast, eigentlich gemacht werden wollte. Nee, das gibt es nicht an allen Schulen, deswegen frage ich.
Okay, und du bist jetzt, darf ich fragen, in welcher Klasse?
In der achten.
Und macht ihr da auch noch Informatik sozusagen, oder?
Na ja, da wird so weitergehend angebunden als Projekt, das ging über eine Woche, eine Multimedia-Präsentation war auch äußerst interessant. Da durften wir im Internet recherchieren, über eine ESN-Leitung, was sehr klasse und schnell war. Und er meinte dann so, ja, auf keine bösen Senden gehen und so, dass ich dann neben Ende zum Protokoll schicken lasse, und gerade auf Contoodit, fahrte über das Netzwerk rüber, ging uns. Und der ist so ein typischer Aurelien, der hat irgendwie, glaubst du, wir haben morgens die Kapazität bei der Netzwerkverteilung, da meinte er dann so, oh ja, das Virus, und so vorunter und so.
Also Paranoide-Lehrer.
Ja, das Älteste war drei Jahre passend, vernünftig war. Das ist so eine Art Internet AG, das mache ich mit drei anderen Leuten noch. Wir machen da unsere Homepage für die Schule und dann steige ich jetzt wahrscheinlich auch bald aus, weil jetzt geht es immer noch nach dem Motto, also wir haben erst zu Anfang ein paar HTML-Tricks gelernt, mittlerweile arbeiten wir mit Initoren. Und jetzt geht es in die Richtung, ja, ich wollte eine Seite für die Notieren machen, okay, da kommt nächste Woche, bevor wir noch nicht antwortet haben, und das kassiert dann die Schule ab, also.
Aber was wäre denn dein Vorschlag?
Verlieren sie es ein? Die kassieren das richtig ab?
Naja, ähm, klar, sicher kriegen die sicher recht Geld dafür. Also wie gesagt, für so eine Firma auch nur eine Homepage machen, denkt man nicht, dass es umsonst ist, und wir haben davon eigentlich nicht so viel.
Das ist ja der Hammer, das ist ja wirklich der Hammer. Das heißt, ihr macht als Internet AG Seiten, und eure Schule kassiert Kohle dafür.
Ja, so in der Art und Einzel, wovon wir bis jetzt profitiert haben, waren wir dann bei dem Plan für Börse damit gemacht. Vielleicht habt ihr davon gehört. Da haben wir den zweiten Platz gemacht, da haben wir den tollen Netzwerk bekommen. Das war auch sehr sinnig. Da wurden drei PCs vernetzt, dafür lässt so eine Firma kommen, statt dass sie uns das machen lässt. Da ist ja auch wieder Geld drauf.
Irgendwo muss er die Kohle, die er ja für eure Homepage kassiert, wieder ausgeben. Das denn?
Ja, das ist aber echt ganz schön hart. Und haben die euch denn, du sagst jetzt da Multimedia-Präsentationen und das ihr da auch im Netz wart, haben die euch denn auch tatsächlich was beibringen können im Sinne von, wie man Suchmaschinen bedient oder sowas? Oder hatten die Lehrer da, wie würdest du denn das Vorwissen der Lehrer im Bezug aufs Internet einschätzen?
Also wir haben einen Lehrer, der ist eigentlich ganz cool so. Ich dachte nur, wenn man so einfach macht, was man gerade nicht zum Thema passt. Unser anderer Lehrer, der ist total spießermäßig und Microsoft-Benutzer. Die restlichen Lehrer, die fahren mal den Server hoch. Ich weiß nicht, welchen Knopf ich drücken soll. Da sind so viele Knöpfe dran. Immer der Power und immer der Abwehrknopf.
Das macht einen unentbehrlich.
Da kann man eine Menge Geld nicht verdienen.
Genau.
Frag mal Ricardo, wie es an seiner Schule ist.
Danke für deinen Bericht.
Tschüss.
Ich bin jetzt gerade in der 12. Ich habe parallel zu dem, was mein Vorgänger gesagt hat, gefunden. Aber ich würde persönlich nicht so auf die Schulen schimpfen. Denn die Schulen sind die, die am wenigsten an der ganze Misere schuld haben.
Aber sind Lehrer nicht selbstständige Menschen, die sich da auch ein bisschen selbst drum kümmern können und das auch sollten, irgendwie am Ball zu bleiben für ihre Schüler? Und nicht darauf warten, dass das Kultusministerium vorschreibt, was sie denn zu wissen haben?
Bei mir persönlich in der Schule muss ich sagen, dass man in Formate, die Lehrer sehr viel tut. Wir hatten erst so ein IPX Netzwerk gehabt, und jetzt mal versucht über einen eigenständigen Server die ganze Geschichte laufen zu lassen. Und er hat in seiner Freizeit versucht, das alles zu installieren und alles fertig zu bringen. Obwohl er eigentlich nicht in eine Firma kommen lassen hätte, die das dann alles eingestellt hätte. Aber das hat der Marc ja als Salene gemacht, weil er die Schule kein Geld hat. Also ich sag mal so, gut, wir haben jetzt, naja, die PCs sind doch halbwegs brauchbar. Also wir haben da jetzt 200 Megahertz-Prozesse drinne.
Kannst du mal kurz sagen, wie viele habt ihr insgesamt?
Wie viele Schüler auch?
Na, 10 vielleicht. Aber ich sag mal so, jetzt in der vierten Klasse ist es bei uns so, dass hier auch nur 8 Schüler in den Kurs drinne sind. Also es sind doch nur andere Bedingungen.
Ja, und ab der vierten Klasse haben Schüler da irgendwie ein Fach, wo ihnen jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ob das bei euch dann Informatik heißt oder ob das ein TG heißt.
Ab der vierten Klasse ist es bei uns, ich glaube die vierten Klasse ist sogar Pflicht, dass man in der vierten Klasse Informatik bekommen. Also so war es ebenfalls da, wo ich war. Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, Sie haben das jetzt schon geändert, aber so war es zum Ändertsein gewesen. Und ich finde, dass die vierten Klasse einfach viel zu spielten ist.
Aber macht ihr da noch Sachen, die jetzt über die reine Technik hinausgehen? Das heißt also das, was wir eigentlich unter Medienkompetenz verstehen, das heißt also wirklich kritisch hinterfragen, was da passiert im Internet, wie die Werbung in die Suchmaschine kommt und so ne Sachen.
Also zum Thema Internet muss ich sagen, dass wir dort sehr schlecht ausgestattet sind. Wir haben ja nicht mal eine ISD-Einleitung. Wir haben, naja, okay, ist doch eine ISD-Einleitung, aber wenn man da, ich weiß nicht, wie es mein Lehrer geschafft hat, er hat einfach an Modem angebastelt für zehn Arbeitsplätze.
Also das ist wirklich ne Katastrophe.
Da war noch mal so ne T-Online-Kampagne gewesen vor, knapp ein Jahr. Da hat man zufällig gewonnen, ja. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch daran erinnert, aber da hat man einen Computer mit einem T-Online-Zugang gewonnen.
Einen Computer mit einem Zugang?
Ja, das war...
Für wie viele Schüler sagt das du noch schnell?
Ich muss dazu sagen, das ist jetzt der beste PC, der wir uns in der Schule vorhanden haben.
Und der ist schon ein Jahr alt.
Der ist schon ein Mr. Pentium 450 oder so. Naja, ich sag mal so, immerhin, der ist ja ein Tool. Nur, ich sag mal so, im Musikunterricht...
Das ist halt nur einer, ne?
Ja, das ist halt nur einer. Erstens sind es Fans im Musikunterricht, das kann man jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz gut einbinden. Weil unser Lehrer hat ja auch einen Plan. Man muss ja auch manche Sachen mit uns eben machen. Er kann ja übrigens sagen, so Leute, nun machen wir heute mal eine Runde Internet. Man muss ja auch gewisse Bildungspläne erfüllen. Und da passt jetzt momentan, ist jetzt einfach noch nicht so stark mit einbezogen.
Also das Internet kommt in den Lehrplänen sozusagen nicht wirklich vor.
Aber ist es denn überhaupt sinnvoll, dass das Internet einfach überall in jeden Lehrplan reingedrängt wird?
Nicht in jeden Lehrplan. Also persönlich würde ich sagen, zum Beispiel im Garten Fachmusik spielte ich ganz stark mit drin. Wenn man sich nur die MP3-Szene anschaut. Also das ist meine Meinung. Also das würde ich sagen, dass die MP3-Geschichte so manche CD oder so ersetzen wird.
Naja klar, ich meine als Distintionskanal, aber damit, ich weiß ja keine Ahnung, was bei Musik in einer Weise vermittelt wird.
Naja, ich sag mal, Musik ist immer so, man stellt sich Musikunterricht vielleicht näher an unserer Klassenschufe. Wir machen das immer so, wir machen mehrere gleichzeitig. Wir haben jetzt drei Wochenstunden und da ist vielleicht eine Stunde für Notenlehrer oder so flach, aber da bleibt ja noch ein bisschen andere Zeit übrig. Also ich glaube schon, dass es eigentlich Platz hätte, da würde man nicht so andere etwas vielleicht Sinnlose machen.
Das heißt, die Lehrer, meinst du, die haben gar nicht die Chance, selbst wenn sie es wollen, weil sie da noch irgendwelche Vorgaben aus dem letzten Jahrhundert haben?
Also auch in Sachen Englisch jetzt. Englisch spielt der Nummer auch ganz stark, also damit hat er auch noch mit unserem Internet zu tun. Und da fragt man schon unser Englischlehrer uns, ob wir ihn nicht von diesem Yahoo, diesen News Server da, ob wir ihn ja nicht Sachen zum Beispiel da runterziehen können auf Englisch, auf Englischer Sprache. Was man eigentlich auch in der Schule alledieren müsste.
Das wäre doch nicht kein Problem.
Das ist mit der Dossan eurer Hausaufgabe.
Ja, also heute war schon wieder so ein Tag gewesen. Sollte ich endlich so eine englische, weiss ich nicht, so bei Armageddon gehen, sollte ich eben da, bei YouTube war der Name von einer Minute gewesen, aber trotzdem.
Ricardo, kräm dich nicht, du hast es bald geschafft. Frag mal jemanden, der noch ziemlich lange durchhalten muss. Danke für dein Name, Ricardo. Felix. Du bist 14 und damit noch recht jung. Fühlst du dich gut beraten von deinen Lehrern?
Nee, eher irgendwie nicht so, denn ich hab schon einige Zeit einen Computer und ich weiß auch gar nicht, ja am Anfang war es ja mehr so spielen, doch jetzt seit überm Jahr eben schon so eher ein bisschen selber was kreieren so und jetzt hab ich eben bei mir seit einem halben Jahr diesen ITG-Unterricht und kann man ja echt beeinschlafen, weil... Ist das fair?... eben alles so beigebracht, wie man die Mausbewegung und das Zeug eben, also das ist total verlangweilig.
Klingt ziemlich sinnfrei und was ist das höchste der Gefühle, was man im ITG vermittelt bekommt? Den Ausschalter oder?
Nee, also wir lernen grad wie man mit Workstick und Kursiv und welcher Schriftart und welche Größe man irgendwas macht.
Ja aber ich finde es schon ziemlich arrogant zu sagen so, dass es irgendwie sinnfrei zu lernen, wie man die ausbewegt, weil irgendwo muss man das ja lernen, also ich meine, dann macht es vielleicht mehr Sinn, die Gruppen zu trennen, die wir schon hatten und die nicht und so.
Ich meine das auch, weil bei mir in der Klasse gibt es wirklich welche, die sind da eben nicht so gut beraten, haben keinen Computer, ich meine, die sollen das ja auch irgendwie lernen und ich finde da sollte man irgendwie auch die Gruppen teilen und somit dann.
Auch wirklich was dazulernen.
Es geht einfach zu den Kursen in der zehnten Klasse oder so.
Wird es was?
Wo gehen denn die aus der zehnten hin, die es schon wissen?
Die können die Siebklässler unterrichten.
Wir hatten bis vor kurzem auch ziemlich schlechte Rechner, also 33 Mhz. Und jetzt zu Ostern haben wir 500 Mhz Computer bekommen, also sind wir eigentlich ganz gut dran. Nach dem Osternferien jetzt auf Windows 98, also ein Internetanschluss.
Gut, ich denke wir nehmen jetzt erstmal die Blöcke der Erfahrungsberichte zu uns und dann können wir noch mal ein bisschen upstream machen.
Danke Felix, danke für deinen Anruf.
Ach, das ist Krux.
Hi Lisa, hallo Anderen. Ähm, ich wollt meinen Erfahrungen auch noch hinterher werfen. Ich hab dann mit Lisa da auch schon ein bisschen gequatscht drüber, wie wir uns Projekte da in den Schulen unterbringen. Und bei mir ist das ja so ähnlich. Also erstmal irgendwie diese harte Ausstattung. Wir haben irgendwie drei Räume, A12-PCs, irgendwie 100 Megahertz, weiß ich nicht, bla bla. Einer ist da von vernetzt, also von den Räumen. Da haben wir inzwischen sogar ein Hardware-Upgrade gekriegt, weil die Firma, die da ihre Office-Schule gemacht haben, denen waren die Rechner zu lahm. Und wir haben auch dieses Kids-Projekt und haben da eben auch so ein Multimedia-PC, der natürlich irgendwie sofort umgewandelt wurde in den ESDN-Router, weil sonst kann man damit ja nichts machen.
Haben das Lehrer oder Schüler gemacht?
Na, das haben Schüler gemacht. Also wir haben da auch so Internet AG, unter der läuft dann halt Homepage für die Schule basteln und Inux machen und so. Die machen, also ich und unser Informatik-Lehrer, muss ich auch mal sagen, also unser Informatik-Lehrer, dem kann man echt sagen, du, wir wollen vielleicht IPv6 machen und dann sagt er klar, was braucht ihr, wie kann man das machen, was ist das, was wir wissen. Also der ist da schon interessierter, würde ich sagen.
Und ab der wievielten Klasse kriegt man bei euch diesen ITG?
Also ITG-Unterricht ist irgendwie nur an Gymnasium, glaube ich. Und da ist das glaube ich in der neunten Klasse.
Ach so, bei euch nicht, oder?
Ja, in Gesamtschule, da kriegt man irgendwie diese Wahlpflichtkurse und da kann man in der neunten dann irgendwie Informatik machen, aufprogrammieren, Toposkal, logischerweise. Und dann, wenn man Abi weiter macht, kann man, wenn man in der neunten Informatik hatte, macht man in der dreizehnten und dann in der zwölften und in der dreizehnten.
Aber neunte kommen ja auch neunte, wie alt sind die in der neunten so? 14, 15. 14, 15, das ist aber auch relativ spät, oder? Ja gut, ich meine, das ist jetzt die Frage sozusagen. Also unser Konzept war jetzt ein bisschen, dass man sagt, irgendwie die reine Technikkompetenz, also das mit der Maus und so, das muss eigentlich so in der fünften, wie die ersten Englischworte kommen.
Na ja, das wollen sie in, was war das, Baden-Württemberg, doch Englisch als Fremdsprache in der Grundschule einführen. Wenn du das kannst, dann kannst du auch Technikkompetenz in der Grundschule einführen.
Ja, weil ich meine, ja es ist auch ganz klar, weil bei Sprachen irgendwie ist es ja mittlerweile allen klar, dass die Jünger mal damit anfängt, dass du einfacher Feld einlässt. Richtig.
Das ist aber bei Computern sicherlich nicht anders.
Eben, genau.
Aber Philipp, wie gut ist denn diese Internet AG besucht? Also gibt es da viele, die sich da irgendwie daran beteiligen und sich da engagieren oder?
Na ja, es waren mal mehr. Sagen wir mal so, im Moment sind zwar glaube je nachdem, wie Ausfallplan und Wetter ist, mehr oder weniger sechs bis sieben Leute in dem Dreh. Mal mehr, mal weniger. Das schwankt halt. Am Anfang waren wir glaube ich irgendwie zwölf und sind dann halt ein paar weniger geworden.
Das ist nicht so viel.
Es gibt aber auch eine Grundschule in der Nähe, die haben sich Rechner besorgt und die haben auch schon in der Grundschule Internetanschluss etc.
Da gibt es schon einige in Berlin.
Ich war mit meiner Schwester in der Schule glaube ich auch so. Die hatten da Max im Klassentimmer und Klicken.
Die Hausmeister, die das machen.
Privatschule.
Nee, nee, nicht Privatschule.
Philipp, danke für deinen Anruf.
Na klar.
Tschüss, machs gut. Jetzt haben wir eben so viel Negativmeinungen gehört, jetzt hören wir uns noch zwei an, die dafür sind. Hallo Florian, du findest Informatikunterricht toll. Florian spricht nicht mit jedem. Versuchen wir es mal mit Annika.
Hallo Annika.
Annika? Das ist verblüffend. Nein, die Leute wollen dann einfach auch mal nicht 10 Minuten warten.
Das ist nicht so schade.
Aber da rauscht dann noch was. Das ist hier.
wir selbst.
Ah, daher kommt die Stimme.
Was? Stimme?
Nichts. Aber ich hörte dich irgendwie an.
Ich hab übrigens eine Mail von einem Hörer bekommen, der mich darum gebeten hat, dass ich doch nicht immer zwischendurch Musik spielen soll, dann schläft er immer ein.
Das ist bedauerlich. Wir wollten jetzt auch mal eigentlich zu der Idee kommen, die wir da hatten, mit dieser Medienkompetenz. Also nehmen wir mal an, es gäbe sagen wir mal ganz harmlos in der fünften, sechsten Klasse, so eine Art Technikkompetenz. Also die Jungs wüssten alle und die Mädels, was eine Maus ist und was ein Betriebssystem ist. Und nicht nur, dass eine Festplatte ein Speicher ist, sondern auch, wie das so funktioniert. Und sie wüssten vielleicht sogar ein bisschen darüber, wie das Internet funktioniert und welche Dienste es da gibt. Und sie wüssten auch, wie ein Fernsehsender funktioniert und sie wüssten auch, wie ein Radio funktioniert und wie Web und Internet sich finanziert und so weiter und fort. Also so ein bisschen, nicht nur was über die Technik, sondern auch über die Konzepte. Und man könnte sozusagen auf dieser Grundlage was aufbauen.
Verstehst du unter Technikkompetenz dann so Handwerksdolz sozusagen?
Ja, Technikkompetenz wäre sozusagen zum einen zu wissen, was die Maus ist, zum anderen aber auch, was ist überhaupt die CPIP und was hat das mit dem Internet zu tun. Beziehungsweise, was ist denn ein Port irgendwie?
Auf der Toransprache, die CPIP und...
Naja, ich meine, man sollte ja, man kann ja zumindest mal, ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass man mal, das kann man auch auf einem einfachen Niveau erklären.
Die Sendung mit der Maus hat das auch geschaffen.
Ich bin auch teilweise bei so Kavattenträgern, denen sag ich dann irgendwie, ja, ihr könnt euch das so vorstellen.
Die Sendung mit der Maus hat die CPIP erklärt, aber uns war sehr gut.
Da schreibt sogar ein Nameserver und...
Echt?
Auf dem Niveau kann man das genau auch, also wie gesagt, ich erkläre das auf Kavattenträgern und die sind auch nicht unbedingt irgendwie neopho- So, den sag ich dir, ihr könnt euch das so vorstellen, das ist eine gemeinsame Sprache, die Computer miteinander sprechen und dann gibt's ja noch Adressen, das ist so wie Telefonnummern und... Ja, so, ich meine, ich hab ja nicht gesagt, dass man die jetzt... Nein, ich will den jetzt nicht Paket für Paket und irgendwie Bit für Bit erklären, aber doch zumindest, dass man mal gehört hat, wie das so im Proben funktioniert, damit man da nicht vor so einem mysterischen Apparat sitzt, mysteriösen und gar nicht weiß, was da auf dem Bildschirm passiert und warum es da passiert, und nur weiß, dass wenn ich mit der Maus da hinklicke, dass dann das passiert. Weil das ist für mich keine Technikkompetenz, sondern das ist irgendwie Schimpansen-Dasein, so, ich würde mir jetzt ein bisschen gemein. Aber so, also gut, mit diesem Anspruch so. Und die Idee, es gab dann mal diese Stichwort Medienkommission, oder was heißt gab es, es gibt es, das ist irgendwie seit... Seit ein paar Jahren wird es diskutiert, da gibt es Medienwissenschaftler. Der Herr Barke ist leider, der sozusagen diesen Begriff in Deutschland geprägt hat, der ist letztes Jahr leider verstorben. Das ist echt dumm gelaufen, denn man war eigentlich noch viel zu jung dafür. Aber er hat immerhin ganz viele Texte hinterlassen und Beiträge hinterlassen so über seine Vorstellungen, was dann Medienkompetenz sein soll. Da geht es auch um Kommunikationskompetenz, nach seinen Vorstellungen.
Ja, vor allem Medienkritik, Medienkunde, also das reine Wissen, was man irgendwie anlernen kann. Und natürlich auch die Frage, wie werden Medien genutzt? Das heißt, was passiert da eigentlich, wenn ich mich da durchbewege? Und so eine Sache. Ja, also Medienkompetenz, da gibt es einfach verschiedene Definitionen. Also der Andi hat irgendwie eine recht einfache...
So einfach ist sie ja auch nicht. Es gab mal eine Enquete-Kommission, die hieß Deutschlands Weg in die Informationsgesellschaft. Ich weiß, da werden jetzt alle lachen. Hat auch nie einer wahrgenommen, ist auch egal. Jedenfalls der Bundestag hat theoretisch nicht mal mit dem Thema beschäftigt. Und dann kam dieses Thema Medienkompetenz auf und keiner wusste, was es bedeutet. Und dann gab es eine extra Anhörung dazu. Und da haben dann verschiedene Leute Modelle präsentiert. Das war relativ flussig. Und da habe ich das mal versucht auf einen einfachen Nenner zu bringen. Ich habe gedacht, okay, ich stelle das hoch vor. Wir haben hier dieses neue Medium, das heißt Internet und so vor Ort. Und da stelle ich mir zumindest vor, dass es da verschiedene Fähigkeiten gibt, die man erkennen muss. Also man muss Lesen neu lernen. Das heißt, man muss wissen, wie man im Medium Information bekommt, wie man sie auch bewertet. Das heißt nicht nur, wie man sie technisch liest, wie ich was auf dem Bildschirm kriege, wie ich eine Suchmaschine bediene, sondern auch, wie ich das bewerte. Weil wenn jeder auf einmal ein Sender ist und ich keinen Lektor habe, der in meinem Buch irgendwie erst mal durchgeht und nach neuer deutscher Rechtschreibreform zensiert oder was auch immer, dann heißt das auch, dass ich mir in die Ankunft muss, was ist die Quelle der Information und wie weit kann ich der trauen, wer steckt dahinter. Allerdings sind das ja Sachen, die nicht nur fürs Internet gelten, sondern die genauso für die Zeitung, Radio, Fernsehen, für diesen ganzen sogenannten alten Medienrahmen genauso gelten. Also Lesen als eine Sache, dann Schreiben heißt mediumspezifische Eigenschaften z.B. berücksichtigen, dass man weiß, dass man da bestimmte Emotionen kann man nicht dadurch ausdrücken, dass man lächelt, während man was in die Tastatur hineingebt, weil eventuell wird das einfach nicht wahrgenommen.
Wenn du das Wort Emotikon sagst, springe ich übers Pult und dir ins Gesicht.
Nein, nein, das sage ich nicht. Ich meine, Gefühle ausdrucken erfordert deutlich mehr, als ein Zeichensatz mit denen, sondern das hat auch was mit sprachlicher Artikulationsfähigkeit zu tun.
Ja, und Falle. Und wenn wir uns auch verbreiten, welche Sachen eben einfach mal nicht im Textchat gehen, was einfach nicht geht.
Genau, und dann eben auch die ganzen Geschichten schreiben heißt dann aber natürlich auch, dass man im Falle der Extremfall auch weiß, was HTML ist zumindest.
Ja, im Falle, dass man wichtige Sachen auch verbreitet.
Also das hat der Tula Tseki gesagt, dass es eben auch wichtig ist, Medien selbst zu gestalten und auch zu verbreiten.
Wer hat das gesagt? Tula Tseki, das ist auch einer der Spruchmedienwissenschaftler.
Ja, aber zumindest der Herr Barke hat mich damals darauf hingewiesen, ja, was ist denn mit dem Kooperieren? Das heißt, was ihm an dem Modell gefehlt hat, ist, dass man ja auch, wenn man tatsächlich, das Medium ist ein Netzwerk, dann muss man ja auch ein Netzwerk da sein sozusagen. Das heißt, die Frage ist, wie ist denn das mit sozialer Interaktion? Das eine ist, dass Medien bedienen können, und das andere ist, auf der anderen Seite sind irgendwie Menschen. Und es gibt da auch innerhalb des CCC einen ganz langen Streit über die Frage, ob denn soziale Netzwerke durch technische Netzwerke entstehen. Oder ob man nicht zumindest soziale Netzwerke durch technische Netzwerke brühen ziehen kann. Oder ob Netz nicht einfach nur Struktur verstärkt hat. Und ohne jetzt allzu viel in diesen internen Auseinandersetzungen, die sehr von Warholland geprägt ist, der eben da eine sehr kritische Auffassung so hat und sagt eigentlich, dass soziale Netzwerke eine Sache für sich sind und technische Netzwerke eine Sache für sich.
Das ist aber schön, wenn die beiden sich begegnen.
Nein, nein, gar nicht, das ist doch in Ordnung. Auf der anderen Seite ist es ja schon so, dass im technischen Netzwerk, im Internetsozialen, da entstehen ja schon auch soziale Netzwerke. Es ist ja nicht so, dass da nicht Leute miteinander reden, die nicht vorher miteinander geredet haben.
Aber gut, so.
Und das heißt, das wäre so ein dreieiniges Konzept. Aber, also lesen, schreiben, kooperieren. Aber es gibt da noch sehr viel weitergehende und auch anders strukturierte. Also es gibt, wenn man sich die unterschiedlichen Medien, die die Wissenschaft anguckt, da gibt es irgendwie tausend von Reihenfolgen, in der die das alle sortieren.
Letztendlich lässt sich aber schon wieder auf die drei Punkte zusammenfassen. Wie eben, weiß nicht, Medienangebote auswählen und nutzen, Medien selbst gestalten und verbreiten, verstehen und bewerten. Das sind eigentlich alles so Sachen, die man letztendlich schon ganz gut unterlesen und schreiben zusammenfassen können. Aber tatsächlich dieses Kooperieren, das kommt so in diesen ganzen Sachen eigentlich nicht wirklich vor. Das ist schon richtig.
So, und jetzt spürt sich die Frage, wenn wir mit diesem naiven Konzept dabei gehen würden. Also ich hab da zumindest mal eine Sache, ich glaube im Politikunterricht haben wir mal so eine Sache gemacht, dass wir mal irgendwie an einem Tag von allen Tageszeitungen, das ist übrigens eine tolle Übung, also an einem Tag sich mal jede Tageszeitung zu kaufen und die einfach mal miteinander zu vergleichen. Das ist immer eine schöne Berufslanderweiterung, wie viele Realitäten es in diesem Land irgendwie gibt. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab hier sowas auch schon mal gemacht, Lisa. Und könntest du dir denn vorstellen mit deinen Lehrern, die du ja von einer Altersgruppe beschrieben hast, auch mal darüber zu reden, dass das Internet sozusagen als Medium verändert?
Na sicherlich kann ich mir das vorstellen.
Können die sich das auch vorstellen?
Das weiß ich nicht, aber es sieht gar nicht so hoffnungslos aus, also meiner Meinung nach.
Also die Frage, das ist ja in so einer Klassensituation, wie sinnvoll das ist, mit Leuten zu diskutieren, die das Medium eigentlich gar nicht so kennen, oder möglicherweise sehr von den Medien, von Zeitungen, Fernsehen usw. geprägt, sind nicht von ihren eigenen Erfahrungen, oder vielleicht die eigenen Erfahrungen sich ja darauf beschränken, halt ein bisschen durch irgendwelche Werbesalten zu klicken oder so.
Na das stimmt, das ist ein Problem. Da müsste man irgendwie eine gemeinsame Grundlage schaffen, um da auf einem akzeptablen Niveau diskutieren zu können.
Wie würde die aussehen?
Wir haben noch anderthalb Stunden Zeit.
Gemeinsame Grundlage könnte zum Beispiel so aussehen, dass man die Mechanismen kennenlernt. Also was Andi sagte, wie finanzieren sich Webseiten, wie das funktioniert, was sind diese komischen Hits und nach welchen Prinzipien werden Webseiten gestaltet. Also das geht ja meistens bei kommerziellen Webseiten auch danach, dass man möglichst viele Hits kriegt und möglichst viele bunte Werbebanner.
Die müssen wir erst aufpoppen, bevor der das da hat.
Ja, wobei es gibt ja kommerzielle und unkommerzielle Webseiten im Gegensatz zum Fernsehen. Es gibt eigentlich kein in dem Sinne unkommerzielles Fernsehen mehr, weil die alle, auch die Öffentlich-Rechtslichen, hängen an der Quotenfrage. Und wenn öffentlich-rechtliche Sender sagen, wir machen jetzt irgendwie intellektuellen Fernsehen und es ist uns egal, ob uns einer zuguckt oder ob da nur zwei Zuhörer sind, weil wir halt nur noch zwei Intellektuelle in diesem Land haben. Die anderen hängen alle bei Big Brother an der Nadel.
Na ja, vergiss Arte und Phoenix und so eine Sachen. Dafür ist eben bei den Öffentlich-Fernsehenden noch Platz.
Ja, okay, das mag sein, aber bei der ARD zum Beispiel nicht.
Nee, gut, aber das ist ja, weiß nicht, eine Fernsehsessionierung ist ja vielleicht auch nicht so schlecht, oder?
Aber früher gab es doch da so ein Modell, also ich glaube, da hat sich im Selbstverständnis was geändert, weil früher war das doch so öffentlich-rechtlich Fernsehen, das war so was wie das Verständnis des Staates, wir alle finanzieren eine gemeinsame Struktur, und die tut dann sinnvolle Dinge für die Gemeinschaft. So, da kamen dann irgendwie Informationen zum Beispiel, da gab es auch noch den Glauben, dass wir in der Demokratie leben und alle diese Dinge. Und ja, und das hat sich insofern denke ich schon ein bisschen gebandet, weil der Sportteil ist mir irgendwie erschreckend zu groß geworden irgendwie. Und auch sonst hat man ja den Eindruck, die wollen nicht mehr informieren, und es geht nicht mehr darum, gesellschaftliche Probleme aufzuzeigen oder was auch immer, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen. Sondern es ist eigentlich, naja, zumindest der Nachteil, ich rede jetzt nicht von Arte, ich rede jetzt von der Arte.
Ja gut, aber selbst wenn du die Nachrichten zwischen Tagesschau und RTL News oder sowas vergleichst, ist da schon noch ein hin und weiter Unterschied. Ja, also schon der Art, irgendwie Art wie zwischen B-Zeitung und Tagesspiegel, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, wo sagt ihr, dass der Unterschied stimmt? Das Bild ist irgendwie rot.
Auch bei dir, wenn ihr aufhört, irgendwie euch über Zeitungen auseinanderzusetzen, das ist so gerade langweilig und gehört eigentlich nicht wirklich zum Thema.
Gut, das gehört dann zum Thema.
Wir wollen ja irgendwie eine Metadiskussion führen. Wir wollen ja nicht eben selbst ausdiskutieren, sondern darüber diskutieren, wie man so eine Themen in der Schule diskutieren kann und wo das hingehört.
Dann machen wir das doch mal zusammen. Vielen Dank. Das war's für heute.
Bildungsoffensive, dafür haben sich in Brandenburg Vertreter von Hochschulen und Wirtschaftsverbänden stark gemacht. Sie forderten von der Landesregierung in den nächsten vier Jahren 380 Millionen Mark zusätzlich. Nur so könne Brandenburg im internationalen Konkurrenzkampf bestehen. Kompromiss, Autohersteller in der EU sollen ab 2007 alle Altfahrzeuge umsonst entsorgen. Darauf einigten sich EU-Ministerrat und Europäisches Parlament in Brüssel. Ursprünglich sollte die Altautorichtlinie bereits ein Jahr früher in Kraft treten. Dafür bleibt es jedoch bei der vollen Kostenübernahme durch die Produzenten. Beschluss. Das Bundeskabinett hat den Einsatz von deutschen Soldaten im Kosovo verlängert. Ursprünglich sollte die zunächst auf ein Jahr begrenzte Bundeswehrmission am 11. Juni beendet werden. Kritik. Das Bundeskartellamt hat die fünf großen Mineralölkonzerne wegen des Preiskriegs zulasten freier Tankstellen abgemahnt. Beanstandet wurde, dass die Konzerne das Benzin an ihren eigenen Zapfsäulen williger verkaufen als an freie Tankstellenbetreiber. Fußball. Real Madrid hat die Champions League gewonnen. Real bezwang am Abend im Finale in Paris den FC Valencia 3-0. Für Madrid war es bereits der achte Erfolg im Wettbewerb der Landesmeister. Wetter. Nachts meist trocken 14 bis 11 Grad, morgen Regenschauer 18 bis 24 Grad. Verkehr. Es liegen keine neuen Meldungen vor.
23.32 Uhr, ein Kurzinfo mit Irina Grabowski.
Spritz präsentiert Stereo Soundworld Stereo Soundworld Die Party mit dem Stereo MC Soundsystem im Waschhaus Potsdam Der First Floor mit Rob Birch und Nick Helm von den Stereo MCs plus DJ Fetish von Terra Nova Rewind Strictly Reggae Raga Dancehall auf dem Second Floor mit Iry Hyphy und Chris The Rock Electro und Future Funk mit Hardy Hart und AB auf dem Third Floor Stereo Soundworld Samstag, 27. Mai im Waschhaus Potsdam präsentiert die Stereo von Tritz.
Ja, da war noch diese Radiosendung, die mich entbreite. Wir wollten noch kurz, weil das klingt jetzt bisher vielleicht alles ein bisschen allzu harmonisch und allzu harmonisch waren wir es gar nicht gelassen. Weil es gibt natürlich Bereiche, die vorhin schon mal angeklangt sind, nämlich, dass die Lehrer immer Sorgen haben, wenn die Schüler vor dem Internet sitzen. Genau. Dann kriegen die immer Stirnrunzeln und wollen immer alles kontrollieren und installieren da Filter und denken sich um Himmels willen, wenn jetzt die Kinder verbotene Inhalte abrufen, wenn die da pornosig abrufen oder Bombsbauanleitungen. Rechtsextremistisches Gedankengut. Und dann fangen die gleich an, hier die Schule anzuzünden, die Lehrerin zu vergewaltigen.
Was mich immer verblüchtert, ich frage mich, wo finden diese Propheten diese Dinge? Weil ich stolper da echt selten drüber.
Ja, da gibt es auch ganz andere Aussagen, aber schon richtig, wenn man da nach Flut findet man das. Das ist nun nicht die Sache. Und wenn du irgendwie losgehst und dann warnhoch so nach Drogensuchten, wirst du die auch finden, denke ich. Aber es gibt da sozusagen zwei Ansätze. Die eine ist, man muss die Jugend und überhaupt die Welt vor den bösen Inhalten beschützen. Und eigentlich sind wir da an der Stelle ein bisschen extremistisch veranlagt und sagen, es gibt überhaupt keine schadhaften Inhalte. Es gibt eigentlich nur nützliche Inhalte, weil es macht ja wenig Sinn, jetzt bestimmte Sachen auszufiltern, die den Jungs und Mädels dann im späteren Leben ohnehin begegnen werden. Und entweder man hat dann gelernt, damit umzugehen, oder man ist dann eben nicht immun gegen solche Sachen. Und das scheitert im Moment unter anderem daran, es gibt irgendwie so ein komisches Gesetz, ich hab es jetzt gerade vom Namen her, müsste ich es raussuchen, da geht es irgendwie um die Verwendung von Lehrgeldmitteln oder so ähnlich. Es dürfen ja beispielsweise auch in Schulen nicht jede Bücher, beliebige Bücher gekauft werden, sondern die Bücher müssen freigegeben sein, von was weiß ich, Kultusminister oder von wem auch immer, und für pädagogisch besonders wertvoll oder was auch immer gehalten werden. Und im Rahmen dessen ist zum Beispiel Internet im Moment noch keine solche Anschaffung. Das klingt absurd, ist aber so, weil man über Internet ja nicht nur zwei für zwei pädagogisch sogenannte wertvolle Inhalte abrufen kann, sondern eben auch Katzen-Scheiße oder was auch immer. Und das ist inwieweit eine Diskussion für sich, wo man aber auch mal klar sagen muss, dass wenn wir sozusagen sagen, wir wollen jetzt irgendwie Medienkompetenz, dann muss das auch heißen und gerade für die alten Medien heißen, dass man eine gewisse Immunität beim sogenannten Medienrezipienten im Rahmen dieses sogenannten Lesens, also Wahrnehmens von Medienprodukten oder sich Einverleiben oder wie wir es auch immer nennen, vor eben Medieninhalten, die vielleicht nicht gut sind. Und da gehört im Teilwirtsfall werbefinanziertes Privatfernsehen in einigen Ausuferungen, wo es dann einfach nur noch darum geht, Adrenalin-Schnöße zu erzeugen und sinnlose Gewalt-Sex-Kombinationen im Bildschirm darzustellen, damit man nicht mehr umschaltet und dann die Werbeblöcke eben ins Gehirn verpasst kriegt. Eben genauso wie entsprechende Internetinhalte, die letztendlich vielleicht dasselbe wollen. Aber da hat nicht den Umweg über...
Oder auch nicht dasselbe wollen, also nicht hinter dem Gate her sind, sondern dahinter ihre ganz persönliche Ideologie zu vorbereiten, die dann vielleicht doch eher fragwürdig ist.
Ja, richtig. Nicht zuletzt so. Und die Frage ist natürlich irgendwie, das ist jetzt irgendwie eine Anforderung. Und die Frage ist, inwieweit kriegt man das bei Lehrern heutiger Bauart, sag ich jetzt mal so ganz blöd, implementiert? Also inwieweit können wir uns tatsächlich jetzt realistisch, wenn wir sagen, wir haben größtenteils Lehrer, die älter als Fuchsig sind, hast du gesagt. Wie weit kriegen wir denen jetzt beigebracht, dass sie keine Angst haben sollen vor rechtsextremen Gedankengut oder vor Pornos auf dem Bildschirm, sondern dass sie im Gegenteil, dass sie im Gegenstand der Diskussion machen wollen. Also bei Pornos ist es ja zum Beispiel so, da gibt es dann irgendwie Sexualkundeunterricht, aber auch da darf nicht alles gezeigt werden. Das hat ja auch Grenzen, da darfst du irgendwie keine durchgehend entkleidet Menschen irgendwie beim Akt zeigen und so fort.
Ja, es ist denke ich auch so ein Unwille der Lehrer, sich überhaupt mit sowas auseinanderzusetzen, aber das bedeutet ja auch, man stößt ja auch an ganz andere Grenzen.
Also ich weiß doch, dass wir mal unserer Mathematiklehrerin, gut, das ist jetzt schon eine Runde her, der haben wir dann irgendwann mal als Klasse zusammen, wie Bratwollgeschenk, den haben wir irgendwie verpackt in Geschenkfolien und so fort, weil das war einfach so als Auflockerungsmaßnahme. Weil man stößt ja auch, wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir wollen sozusagen Lehrer, die nicht nur damit klarkommen, sondern das gerade zu fördern, dass wenn irgendwie die Klasse vor dem Internet sitzt und sich da einer Pornos abruft, dann sollen die nicht sagen, du gehst jetzt raus und darfst jetzt nicht mehr ans Internet, sondern dann sollen die das thematisieren. Und dazu müssen wir auch selber erstmal entsprechend die Medienkompetenz haben.
Das ist nicht ein großes Problem bei den Eltern. Weil die Eltern, die stehen nämlich da und sagen, oh mein Kind darf hier nicht und so.
Aber sind Eltern heute auch noch so verspannt?
Also wenn da irgendwie angenommen, wir fangen in der siebten Klasse mit Internet an, also in der Schule. Und dann kommen die kleinen Siebenklässler nach Hause und sagen, Mami, Mami, wir haben uns im Unterricht vorn ausgeguckt. Na was meinst du, was da los ist? Also das gibt Ärger ohne Ende. Und das wollen die Lehrer auch nicht riskieren. Also nicht so einen Stress zu machen.
Also was da ganz gute Erfahrungen gebracht hat, sind so Schüler-Eltern-Kurs. Das heißt also, dass irgendwie Schüler mit ihren Eltern zusammen irgendwie in die Schule oder irgendwo hin geladen werden. Und die dann da unter medienkompetente Aufsicht sozusagen dann surfen. Und da kriegen die Eltern aktuell okay. So und so, das kann halt passieren, das und das nicht. Und scheiße, sie müssen sich jetzt einfach mit ihren Kindern ransetzen, weil das ist einfach so. Und das wird auch immer so sein. Und es wird auch irgendwie nie ein sauberes Internet geben. Genauso wenig, wie irgendwie abends im Fernsehen eben auch rumgefügelt.
Okay, aber das sind jetzt eigentlich zwei unterschiedliche Probleme. Das eine Problem ist, ist die kompetenten Lehrer zu finden. Und das andere die kompetenten Eltern zu finden. Und es mag schon sein, dass die Eltern mitunter auch ein Problem sind. Aber ich hab neulich einen Bericht, da war ich auf so einer Veranschauung, da hat eine Pädagogin berichtet, wie sie eben genauso einen betreuten. Also mit Eltern zusammen, Eltern und Schüler. Und es gab wohl auch genug PCs. Und sie hat den Computerraum aber übernommen, nachdem da irgendwie eine Gruppe 15-Jähriger drin war, die dann einfach die Homepage bei den Netzgeldingern komplett auf irgendwie XXX gestellt haben. Das heißt, die Eltern haben sie dahingesetzt. Dann hat der Lehrer gesagt, sie machen hier den Netzgab auf. Und dann gab es da erst mal Porno vom Feinsten. Und das fanden die halt irgendwie nicht besonders, wie soll ich sagen. Also da gab es dann verspannte Reaktionen. Aber die verspannteste Reaktion kam, glaube ich, gar nicht. Also ich habe den Bericht halt bekommen von der, in Anzeichen betreuenen Pädagogin. Und die hat das also in einem, die hat sich da irgendwie produziert auf dieser Veranschauung. Und hat also da ihren Herbstkasper nochmal nachgespielt. Das ginge doch nicht so. Man könne doch nicht irgendwie Eltern und Schülern überhaupt und Pornos. Also die war damit sichtlich überfordert, würde ich mal ganz freundlich sagen. Und die Frage ist, ja, irgendwie geht das überhaupt mit solchen Ausbildungspersonalen? Das ist offenbar selber nicht. Damit herkommt man Menschen am Bildschirm zu sehen. Und irgendwie kann man von denen erwarten, dass sie dann auf die Eltern entsprechend zugehen und sagen, hören sie mal zu, das ist nur ein nackter Mensch, hier geht es irgendwie nicht um eine Verbrechung oder so. Sondern gerichteweise hat die Natur die Menschen sogar so geschaffen. Wobei, also Moment, also wie soll ich sagen?
Ja, das war keine Frage.
Na doch, das war die Frage irgendwie.
Ja, natürlich brauchen wir konzentrieren, neue Lehrer. Und ich weiß nicht, ob die Lehrer, die es jetzt gibt, dafür so furchtbar geeignet sind. Weil die eben darauf fixiert sind, 30 Jahre lang oder was, haben eben immer das Gleiche gemacht. Und die jetzt noch umzutulen, wäre vermutlich aufwendiger, als einfach von Grund auf... Neue Menschen, also nicht neue Menschen, sondern andere Menschen darauf zu trimmen. Also jetzt nach diesem Medienkompetenzkonzept...
Ich meinte jetzt auch, wie würdest du das denn bei den Eltern als un... also richtig problematisch ansehen oder glaubst du, dass wenn man das mit dem entsprechenden Kompetenzlehrer angeht, dass man dann auch damit klarkommt, dass die sich da Pornos abrücken können und das auch machen?
Na, die breite Masse wird sicherlich, wenn das ein bisschen kommuniziert wird, akzeptieren. Das wird es bei meinen Eltern geben, die da ganz großartige Hardliner sind. Was auch immer. Aber das gibt es ja immer.
Das ist allerdings richtig, ja. Und ich meine gut, aber das ist sicherlich auch eine Hemmschwelle, denke ich mir, warum Lehrer da nicht so völlig entspannt rangehen an das Thema. Ich weiß nicht, kannst du mal ein bisschen von deinen Erfahrungen rücken? Du hast ja sowohl mit Lehrern als auch mit Eltern in dem Zusammenhang zu tun.
Das ist richtig, wobei die Auseinandersetzungen, gerade was das Thema irgendwie über Pornografie oder Sex im Internet angeht, ist extrem schwierig, weil natürlich, du sagst, es sind nur ein paar nackte Menschen, es sind ja einfach mal nicht ein paar nackte Menschen, sondern da wird halt wirklich Hardcore geboten, da gibt es irgendwie Sex mit Tieren und alles. Und das ist teilweise wirklich in Leuten echt schwer zu vermitteln, in der Praxis, warum man das nur irgendwie 12-jährigen Kindern oder 13-jährigen Kindern zumuten soll. So, und da kannst du wirklich lange sagen, irgendwie, ja, das ist vielleicht pädagogisch wertvoll, aber das ist einfach mal nicht die Wertvorstellung unserer Gesellschaft, dass irgendwie 13-jährige Kinder irgendwie Sex mit Tieren vorgesetzt kriegen.
Ja, aber genau das war das Thema auf der Veranstaltung. Sie hat nämlich genau gesagt, ja, stellen Sie sich doch vor, welche Auswirkungen das hat, wenn irgendwie jetzt ein 12-jähriger, das waren genau so ungefähr Ihre Worte, wenn das jetzt irgendwie sieht, wie irgendwie ein Mann Sex mit einem Pferd hat. Und dann habe ich sie halt gefragt, ja, okay, was glauben Sie denn? Geht er danach los und vergewaltigt sein Hamster? Oder lacht er da vielleicht einfach nur drüber und sucht das Gespräch mit jemandem? Also meine, die Frage ist ja, ob du eine Reflektionsebene für Medieninhalte in so einem Fach irgendwie bietest und aufbaust?
Die Frage ist ja, ob 12-jährige daran glauben, sowas schon sinnvoll zu reflektieren.
Na, wenn da jemand neben Ihnen sitzt und mit Ihnen redet und Ihnen die Fragen beantwortet, dann glaube ich das schon.
Ja, aber glaubst du wirklich, dass ein Lehrer das für 35 Kinder in der Klasse machen kann?
Nee, bei 35 auf gar keinen Fall. Aber bei 35 ist in den meisten Schulklassen, das hängt ein bisschen von der Altersgruppe und vom Thema ab, aber ist das sowieso kein Unterricht mehr, sondern das ist dann nur noch irgendwie Beaufsichtigung, Beaufsichtigung von quasi inhaftierten Schülern oder so. Das hat ja nix mehr mit medikumischen Verzeihung zu tun.
Das muss ja auch noch nicht mal zwingend als Diskussionsgrundlage im Unterricht genommen werden, dass da eventuell Pornografie im Internet existent ist und sich angeschaut werden kann. Aber wenn die Fragen auch noch... Wenn der Lehrkörper es schaffen würde, es den Schülern vernünftig zu verkaufen, was es da alles an nützlichen Sachen gibt, dann hören die vielleicht gar nicht erst auf die Idee kommen, sich diese Dinge anzugucken, zumindest die ganz jungen.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich meine, in dem Moment, wo man sagt, das und das ist verboten, hast du natürlich immer welche.
Nein, aber in dem Moment, wenn ich hingehe und sage, da gibt es eigentlich was, was geil ist, und gar nicht erst sagen kann, das nicht einmal so ungeil ist.
Da kann ich berichten von einem Kurs von einer Gruppe, die ich hatte mit sieben Jungs, das war also Internet-Einführung, die waren zwölf und dreizehn. Da war natürlich ganz klar, was sie machen, alle Seiten, wo es Tippen zu sehen gibt, abzusurfen. Da dachte ich, okay, lässt du die mal, sagst du, dass es andere sinnvolle Sachen gibt, nach drei Wochen wird ihnen langweilig werden. Nein, es wird ihnen nicht langweilig. Sie machen einfach nichts anderes, als ein Klicken.
Genau so ist das mit diesen Chatten, das ist ganz krankhaft. Bei uns in der Schule wird jetzt durch diesen Proxy alles gefiltert, wo Chat in der Adresse vorkommt. Aber vorher, die haben einfach nicht aufgehört. Die ersten paar Wochen dachten wir, dann lassen wir sie doch einfach chatten.
Ich meine, das sehen wir ja auch bei deiner Schwester, die irgendwie noch ein bisschen jünger ist und die irgendwie gerne mal diese Clubräume besucht und da chattet. Aber mal im Ernst, ich stelle mir doch die Frage, ist Chatten nicht deutlich besser für eine 12- 13- 14-Jährige oder was auch immer?
Das ist richtig, aber sie tun einfach nichts anderes.
Im Gegensatz zu irgendwie in dem Zeitraum von der Klasse.
Ja, aber wäre es nicht vielleicht besser, sich mit den Leuten draußen zu treffen und sinnvoll austauschen, irgendwie uns ein Buch zu lesen oder so?
Aber wenn das nicht der Reiz ist, sondern wenn der Reiz darin besteht, das über eine Tastatur zu machen, klar kannst du immer sagen, was besser wäre. Natürlich wäre es besser Schinder statt Rinder.
Das ist doch aber irgendwie keine Kompetenz.
Es findet doch keine Handelsersetzung mit der Technik statt oder mit dem Medium.
Genau, gar keine.
Okay, dann gibt es aber zwei Konzepte. Mein Konzept wäre zumindest zum ganz großen Teil erstmal eine Erfahrungsfläche. Ich gehe eigentlich davon aus, in dem Moment, wo du deinen elektronischen Spielgarten hinstellst und die einfach machen lässt, und wenn sie eine Frage haben, ist da jemand da, der ihnen das sinnvoll beantworten kann. Das ist irgendwie das eine Konzept. Und das andere wäre, dass du da strukturierst, angehst und sagst, wie toll das alles ist und da gibt es die wertvollen Inhalte.
In der Praxis ist es aber so, dass die Jugendlichen dann kaum noch aufnahmefähig sind für irgendwas Sinnvolles. Das kann ich aus meiner Erfahrung berichten.
In welchem Moment? In dem Computer, wo sie Pornos gesehen haben?
Jetzt sitzen da ohne Ende Leute, die fragen sich, was ist das für eine Erfahrung, wo hat der die gemacht? Erzähl doch nur mal kurz.
Ich bin als Dozent oder auch mit Jugendgruppen der ein oder andere Mal unterwegs in den letzten Jahren. Das war vielleicht alle zwei Monate mal. Und habe da einfach auch Kurse gemacht. Unter anderem gab es auch ein Projekt, das sich ausgiebig mit dem Chatten beschäftigt hat. Das ist ein grafisches Chatsystem, wo nebenbei aber auch noch so ein Umfeld geschaffen wurde, wo man eben über das reden konnte, was man da erlebt hat. Es wurden versucht, Chatpartnerschaften aufzubauen, sich selbst zu gestalten. Es gab eine Möglichkeit, den Chats selbst zu gestalten, also eine richtige virtuelle Welt aufzubauen. Und das war der Anreiz für mich da auch mitzumachen. Weil es die Möglichkeit gab, außerdem noch, außer diesem einfachen Chatten, was auch spannend ist, aber dass die Leute selbst auch noch ein bisschen was erfahren, ein bisschen was davon mitkriegen und das auch nochmal reflektieren können. Das fand ich so ganz spannend und es war auch ganz wichtig für die Leute, dass sie einfach ein bisschen mehr gelernt haben, was da noch irgendwie passiert und das Ganze auch nochmal ein bisschen überdenken konnten.
Ja, sowas ist dann schon wieder ein betreutes Chatten. Aber was denn bei uns zum Beispiel in der Schule abgelaufen ist, die ersten paar Wochen, war, dass sie eben alleine da saßen. Also die hat keiner begleitet oder da wurde nicht reflektiert, sondern das wurde einfach exzessiv genutzt. Und die haben auch einfach mal gedacht, na ja, irgendwann kommen sie schon drauf. Aber die sind nicht drauf.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja jetzt nicht das Konzept, sondern das ist ja eher noch der Zustand der Mangel, wie Pädagogik oder so ähnlich. Also der Abwesenheit von pädagogischen Konzepten in einem Bereich, wo die eigentlich echt gefahrt wären.
Richtig, weil einfach auch keine Fachkompetenz da ist, haben wir auch nicht die Möglichkeit, jetzt offensichtlich auf die Leute zuzugehen und sagen, ich habe hier aber noch ein bisschen Hintergrundinfos anzubieten.
Ja, wobei, das ist jetzt gerade die Frage, meinst du da jetzt gerade Technikkompetenz oder meinst du da jetzt gerade Medienkompetenz?
Nicht schon, ja beides.
Ich meine, das hängt natürlich zusammen, weil in dem Moment, wo ein Schüler irgendwie eine 5 Jahre Computer Erfahrung hat und der Lehrer, der gerade weiß, wo der Anschalter ist, ihm versucht, etwas von pädagogisch wertvollen Inhalten zu erzählen. Das ist natürlich die Glaubwürdigkeit.
Na ja, gut, aber so ein paar Basics, zum Beispiel wie das mit der Werbung funktioniert und wie irgendwie Interessensgeschichten in den Medien ablaufen, so einen Hintergrund kannst du ja schon mitbringen, reinbringen als Lehrer. Das geht ja schon. Vielleicht auch nicht so medienspezifisch, aber...
Aber wie würdest du denn das Verhältnis zwischen Spielwiese und der Vermittlung von Medienkompetenten sozusagen als jetzt aktives Vermitteln von Inhalten, wie würdest du das gestalten?
Hm, schwer, naja, vielleicht 50-50 schon.
Also 50% Theorie sozusagen, oder?
Wobei Theorie heißt eben auch diskutieren. Also nicht nur irgendwie konsumieren im Sinne, dass da vorne Lehrer steht, sondern einfach auch wirklich mit den anderen Leuten zu diskutieren. Über zum Beispiel Wertvorstellungen. Also ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass in der 7. Klasse dass die Leute da schon unterschiedliche Ansichten darüber haben, wie viel sie im Netz zu sehen bekommen sollten oder wie viel sie zu sehen wünschen und irgendwie also was andere dazu meinen oder was sie vielleicht glauben, was ihre Eltern vielleicht irgendwie okay finden würden und was vielleicht der Rest der Gesellschaft okay finden würde und warum das so ist. Das sind ja alles so Sachen, über die man dann reden kann. Und da denke ich, dass du schon...
Ich wollte hier aber sagen, das ist elementar, dass da tatsächlich nicht 35 Leute sitzen, sondern naja, so Gesprächsrunden von 10, 12 Leuten werden da am besten.
Ist das irgendwie vielleicht, wenn wir jetzt mal zum Maßnahmenkatalog übergehen würden, wäre das jetzt die Forderung 1 irgendwie?
Kleinere Klassen, natürlich, seit 30 Jahren gibt es glaube ich die Forderung, oder seit 20 Jahren, aber ja. Das ist eine gute Forderung, können wir mal aufschreiben.
Kommt so wahrscheinlich aus der Zeit, wo Herr Weizsäcker noch Bundespräsident war und immer so ein ganz tolles Konzept hatte, lebenslanges Lernen, die ganze Gesellschaft, auch die Lehrer und Politiker müssten einig und so weiter und fort. Da hat er, wie immer gesagt, wurde dann geklatscht und dann wieder vergessen.
Natürlich.
Herzog hat es auch wieder rausgeholt.
Ja, natürlich. Frau wird es auch tun.
Ahja, die hat es auch schon.
Wir sind immer noch ein bisschen beim Thema Medienkompetenz und wie soll das praktisch ablaufen? Und jetzt mal abgesehen von den beiden Forderungen, die wir jetzt schon zusammen haben, nämlich kleinere Klassen und lebenslanges Lernen.
Sollte daneben auch irgendwie das so aussehen, dass da nicht jemand ist, der vorne steht und erzählt und die Schüler hören zu, sondern in solchen Diskussionsgruppen soll das eher so ablaufen, dass die Schüler sich gegenseitig was beibringen, weil sie ja doch noch ein bisschen schneller lernen als vielleicht ihre Lehrer und dass da am Kompetenzenten eigentlich sind. Und der Pädagoge soll dann eigentlich mehr die Rolle einnehmen, also im Hintergrund stehen und die Diskussion irgendwie in eine bestimmte Richtung lenken. Also, dass man da auch ein bisschen umdenkt, was die Rolle des Lehrers angeht in so einem Unterricht.
Fällt dich daraus die These abzuleiten, dass man Medienkompetenz einfach gar nicht vermitteln kann in dem Sinne, sondern nur irgendwie Erfahrungen sinnvoll erklären kann.
Also für den Begriff Medienkompetenz würde ich das schon so sagen. Man kann Hintergrunde vermitteln, wie funktioniert das eben mit Werbung und wie finanzieren sich solche Dinge, blablabla. Aber Medienkompetenz an sich kann eigentlich nur in der Diskussion untereinander entstehen.
Das heißt also durch das Abgleichen von verschiedenen Vorstellungen und verschiedenen Realitäten der Medien.
Mehr auch von einem Angleichen von Werten, oder?
Oder indem man sich vielleicht auch mal aufeinander prasseln lässt.
Ja, sicher.
Deswegen, also die Frage ist, gibt es da nicht auch große Ängste vor Disharmonie einfach? Ich könnte es dir vorstellen.
So ein Problem, das bei uns in der Schule gab, hat jetzt nichts mit Medien zu tun, sondern mit dem dritten Reich. Als es eigentlich hätte im Geschichtsunterricht behandelt werden sollen, ist es wirklich weggenuschelt worden innerhalb kürzester Zeit, weil diese Lehrerin, die ich da hatte, einfach ein ungeheures Problem damit hatte, überhaupt dieses Thema anzugehen, weil wir nämlich in der Klasse einen hatten, der gesagt hat, alles Quatsch. Du hast so einen richtig schönen Revisionisten in der Klasse gehabt, der auch, weißt du, du kennst die Brüder, die haben ja dann auch, weiß ich nicht, Argumente bis zum Untergang. Und es ist einfach nicht gemacht worden, weil da überhaupt nicht seitens der Lehrer glaube ich auch die Bereitschaft oder der Wille oder das Vermögen beherrscht, da in den Konflikt einzutreten. Und das müsstest du, wenn es um Pornografie im Netz geht.
Die Frage ist eben, ob das nicht sozusagen, ob wir mit der fordern, wenn wir das jetzt in den Maßnahmenkatalog aufnehmen, und das tun wir ja gerade, ob das nicht sozusagen bisherige pädagogische Konzepte komplett in Frage stellt. Weil das ist das, was du jetzt gerade gesagt hast. Das ist eine eigene Wendung. Da steht normalerweise jemand von und erzählt halt was. Und dann kann man vielleicht noch eine praktische Übung dazu machen. Oder mit Diskussionen.
Das ist ja das Problem, was die Unis gerade haben. Also gerade in den Informatikstudien, da haben die Professoren, die haben an sich auch keine große Existenzberechtigung mehr. Weil irgendwie mit der Entwicklung Schritt halten. Und irgendwie müssen die genauso wie die Studierenden. Und irgendwie Bücher lesen, können die Leute eigentlich auch allein. Und zum Fragen beantworten gibt es da auch keinen mehr. Also das ist halt irgendwie schwierig. Ja, naja, aber was sollen die Leute da irgendwie hochbezahlt da vorne stehen? Und irgendwas aus irgendwelchen aktuellen Fachzeitschriften vorlesen, was die Leute einfach so machen.
Machen sie lieber hochbezahlte Leute auf.
Ja, ich meine, für diejenigen, der hochbezahlter steht, gibt es immer einen Grund, da zu stehen, um nicht hochbezahlt zu werden. Aber die Frage ist, ob sie es am pädagogisch still machen.
Und ob die das auch wissen.
Ja, und wir haben ja seit letzter Woche hier was eingefuehrt und das nennen wir, äh, wie nennen wir ihn?
Andy?
Wie nennen wir ihn?
AOL-Zugange für Schulen kostenpflichtig. Der Internetprovider Amerika Online hat sein Angebot an Schuhe relativiert. Den Internetzugang müssen sich die 46.000 Schulen in Deutschland nun doch selbst suchen, um den AOL-Dienst nutzen zu können. Kostenfrei sind lediglich die Online-Angebote bei AOL nicht der Zugang. Windows CE Handheld gestartet. Der HP Genader, der erste mit dem neuen Windows CE gebaute Organizer, hat ein Problem. Er kann nur ca. 4000 der versprochenen 65.000 Farben darstellen. Pech gehabt. NC für Informatik. CloudFocus haben die Berliner Unis beschlossen, im nächsten Jahr eine Numerus Klausus für Informatik einzuführen. An der TU gibt es derzeit 800 Bewerber für 300 Studienplätze. Wieder ein Notebook geklaut. Der britische Geheimdienst hat zurzeit eine extreme Pechsträne, was Laptops mit sensiblen Daten angeht. Gerade letzte Woche ist wieder ein Gerät abhandengekommen. Das Exemplar wurde einige Tage später für 25.000 Dollar der Redaktion einer Zeitung angeboten. Patent für Patent. Der Patentierungswahn hat Anfang Mai einen Höhepunkt erreicht. Eine amerikanische Firma hat ein Verfahren zur Anmeldung von Patenten patentieren lassen.
Vielen Dank Irina Grabowski. Chaosradio 50, 2 noch 12 übrigens.
Was?
2 noch 12, wollen wir die Uhrzeit anziehen?
Ja, in der Stunde des Chaosradio Nr. 50 wollten wir nämlich auch noch einige Fragen stellen. Und wir würden uns natürlich insbesondere wahnsinnig freuen, wenn sich ein Lehrer oder eine Lehrerin vielleicht eine Frau oder drei oder drei anzugucken. Weil uns interessiert nämlich, was haltet ihr davon? Wie wäre das eventuell eine Möglichkeit mal so ein Fach einzuführen? Ist das total fehl am Platz? Findet ihr das total bescheuert? Ist Technikkompetenz dann tatsächlich ein Problem oder nicht?
Medienkompetenz, also wie wichtig ist eigentlich die Medienkompetenz in der Schule? Ist sie genauso wichtig, irgendwie, wie Deutsch, wie Kunst, wie Sport, wie Musik?
Mit was?
Na, politische Weltkunde.
Das ist ein Wort, das es bei mir dann noch nicht gehabt hat. Herr Margun, was ist denn mit Ihrer Laune los?
Die Podline ist geschaltet.
0331 für Podstar, 70 97 110.
Lehrer vor, habt Mut und beweist Medienkompetenz, indem ihr in den Medien anruft.
An der anderen natürlich auch.
Und solange er noch keine anruft, können wir noch mal kurz über britische Laptops reden, weil die Sande ist ja ziem.
Irgendjemand hatte uns vorhin eine Mail geschrieben und interessante Sachen und der hat uns nicht wieder gemeldet.
Ja, der Herr Meier hat eine Mail geschrieben, der war tätig, Multimedia Internet Infocenter der Kinder- und Jugendbibliothek und so weiter und fort. Ich hatte dem auch gleich zurückgemailt, dass er doch bitte seine Telefonnummer schicken soll, aber leider hat er es nicht getan. Und weil wir jetzt keine Nummer haben, würden wir uns freuen, wenn er sich meldet.
Und ich lasse nochmal ansagen hier.
Die Frips-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Podstar, 7097 110.
Bitte Herr Meier.
Genau. Und hier noch mal kurz zu den britischen Laptops, weil das war nämlich nicht so. Vor vier Wochen ist der erste, also das ist irgendwie so gekommen, dass ein offenbar stark betrunkener Agent des britischen Geheimdienstes in der U-Bahn sein Laptop gelöst hat. Und auf diesem Laptop waren irgendwie hochgeheime Daten und so weiter und so fort. Und das hat ihn irgendwie sehr erbost. Aber was es richtig fuchstig gemacht hat, ist, dass heutzutage, wenn Leute ein Laptop klauen, dann sind die vielleicht auch einfach nur doofe Laptop-Diebe. Aber auch die durven Laptop-Diebe haben heutzutage Internet-Anschluss. Und diese Daten, diese super streng klassifizierten Daten, sind einfach mal komplett im Netz aufgetaucht. Und das hat die wohl minder entspannt gemacht. Und es ist so, es gibt halt ein paar Leute im Internet, die haben irgendwie entsprechende Kohle und entsprechende Server. Und die stellen dann so gefundenen Dokumente von Geheimdiensten, die sammeln die und stellen die auf ihrem Server. Ich hab mir das ausgedruckt, das Hochspann, das kam über lybische Agentengruppen und was nicht alles. Also ist zumindest als Unterhaltungslink über...
Möchtest du mir den Link mal?
Kein Problem, ist irgendwie auf yja.com drauf. Der nächste Punkt war dann, mittlerweile haben dann die Diebe der Laptops, der britischen Agentenlaptop voll festgestellt, dass man daraus ja auch Kohle machen könnte. Und den, den sie jetzt geklaut haben, den haben sie eben in verschiedenen Zeitungen dann angeholt und haben gesagt, ey, der Maisbietende kriegt ihn irgendwie. Und wir gucken mal, wie sich das weiterentwickelt und solange reden wir noch über Medienkompetenz mit Hörern.
Ja, und da haben wir hoffentlich einen kompetenten Menschen dran.
Also eigentlich Medienplaner, aber ich hab dann eine pädagogische Zusatzausbildung gemacht später. Also ich hab richtig Medienbereiche gelernt. Und ich bin jetzt nach Hause gekommen, hab mal zufällig rein gehört bei euch. Also sind halt ein paar heiße Themen hochgekommen. Erstmal anzumerken wäre, Schule muss ich euch im Prinzip recht geben. Sieht also katastrophal aus und bei mir ist es doch so, ich bin eigentlich schon im Freizeitbereich tätig. Ich mache halt viele Honorarprojekte. Und das läuft halt so, wirklich werden eigentlich die Kids rausgefiltert, die Interesse haben. Man sucht auch inzwischen danach. Und die treffen sich halt in bestimmten Einrichtungen. Also zum Beispiel Tiergarten Jugendförderung macht sehr viel. Die machen ja Projekte auch bei Büchereien, also so richtig Internet-Cafés sind. Dann gibt es halt das Clip-Medienzentrum, was sehr gut ist. Kann man empfehlen. Also die machen natürlich auch mit Videotechnik ein bisschen, also sehr kombiniert. Und was eigentlich auch noch sehr gut ist, ist das Zitruller Palmezentrum in Berlin, ein Internet-Café, also haben wir auch eine Mädchen-AG, und die haben das also gesponsert bekommen über die Bank, also über eine Berliner Bank halt, eine bestimmte. Und das sind so Sachen, die ganz gut laufen.
Sie sitzen ja auch im gleichen Haus. Sie sitzen ja auch im gleichen Haus.
Also das ist einfach so. Schule, muss ich gar nicht recht nehmen, ist blöd. Und ich kann noch mal von der Labby erzählen, damit wir seit acht Jahren mit der Labby sehr gut zusammen sind. Was ist das? Landesspielstelle. Ja, genau, das ist halt so, dass die Lehrer, die da hinkommen und Kurse machen, die machen im Prinzip Grundkurse. Das heißt also, das ist mehr so ein Pflichtprogramm.
Ist das so, was die da lernen in diesen Grundkursen?
Na ja, die lernen halt auch Vorkurse. Also das heißt Hardware, Software, denn wie gesagt Mausbedienung. Und die Maschinen sind ja auch nicht gerade die Neuesten. Die Labby hat ja auch Probleme finanziell. Und das ist dann halt so, dass diese Leute dann eben meinen, das reicht halt aus an der Schule, dass sie da mit sprechen können. Und das Problem ist dann eben, dass sie natürlich auch nicht irgendwie zugehen wollen, dass sie dann da die Anschlusskurse fielen. Das ist halt die eine Geschichte. Die andere Geschichte ist halt, also das System Schule und Internetzugang beziehungsweise Freischaltung. Ich meine, so auf der einen Seite sind es sogar Kostenpläne und Kostenlisten. Und die Schulen haben da halt ehrgepische Schwierigkeiten über Landesschulen. Die haben diese halt, diese Kosten nachweisen sollen, wenn die da jetzt ein ganzes Teil herumsaufen oder chatten. Da gibt es halt bestimmte Etat. Das wird einfach eben nicht gar nicht gesehen. Das ist ungefähr wie im öffentlichen Dienst mit Telefonleitungen. Wobei die jetzt ja krampfhaft immer rauskriegen, wer denn wann wo spricht. Und wenn die jetzt ISDN-Anschlüsse haben, was meinst du, was da los ist? Also so. Und dann noch was anderes, was ihr von mir sagt zu der Sexproblematik. Also ich kann dir als eigene Erfahrung sagen, ich mache halt nur noch so Sportangebote. Wir haben ja ziemlich multikulturelle Zähne in Berlin. Ich würde nur mal sagen, als ich verliege hoch im Sportsfeld, hier sind die Mädchen, die müssen ein Kopftuch tragen. Du kannst dir vorstellen, was meine Eltern mir erzählen wollen, wenn ich jetzt eine Kurse mache und sage, ich habe da jetzt irgendwelche Tiersex-Szenen vorgeführt. Das war meine Stellung, die wir in drei Tagen beendet. Diese Jugendförderung ist auch sehr streng, so kann man sie vergessen.
Na ja, klar, aber die Frage ist ja, es geht ja nicht darum, dass man sowas absichtlich vorführt, aber wenn man einen Internetanschluss, hat man halt einen Internetanschluss. Und wenn du da ein Kit hast, das jetzt unbedingt die Provokation sich geben will, auch weil es vielleicht dich ärgern will, dann hast du eben solche Bilder auf dem Bildschirm. Und die Frage ist, ist damit umzugehen? Oder würdest du das als ein Riesenproblem ansehen?
Na ja, ich arbeite immer in diesem Spannungsfeld. Also als Mann ist es so ein bisschen schwieriger als als Frau. Das ist halt einfach heutzutage so aufgrund der belgischen Geschichten, die da halt gelaufen sind, dass die Jugend von irgendwo hergerutscht geworden sind. Und ich kann dir jetzt mal aktuell sagen, gibt da diese Problematik Love Parade? Da sind halt eh nicht, da gibt es halt diesen großen Streit der Eltern. Lass ich meine Kinder hin, lass ich sie nicht hin. Wann können die hin? Das ist natürlich im Internet überspitzt. Das Internet ist für die Eltern sinngemäß, wenn ich jetzt mal so in die Spreche führe, ist das wie so eine Freiraumzone. So eine Art Piraterie. Sie haben dann eine tierische Angst vor, dass ihre Kinder da irgendwie erstens mal einen Business-Vorsprung erwerben und dann natürlich auch eine völlig kompetente Freizeitgestaltung gewinnen. Das wird natürlich wieso nicht Janin sehen. Das ist schon mehr eine ideologische Arbeit als eine technische Bekämpfung. Wie gesagt, ich kann halt nur den Kistenraten oder so Leute, die anrufen, sich wirklich mehr im Freizeitbereich zu orientieren. Ich mache das unverstärkt gerade so, jetzt ab der Altersstufe 18, 9 Jahre. Nicht erst warten, bis sie in die 10. oder 10. Klasse kommen, sondern früher schon gucken, wo sind coole Freizeiteinrichtungen, weil die wollen halt untereinander auch chatten und sich kennenlernen, weil das ja eben doch interessant ist, also so auszutauschen am Tage mit irgendwelchen anderen Einrichtungen. Es gibt auch zum Beispiel Jogreis, das ist so eine Jugendzeitung, die ziemlich cool ist, da sind eine ganze Menge gemacht und so was, um die Qualität aufzusuchen.
Aber habe ich dich richtig verstanden, dass auch den Eltern das teilweise einen mentalen Problem macht, dass wenn die Kinder sich auf einmal in einem Bereich mehr auskennen als sie?
Naja, das Problem ist halt, dass heute alles irgendwie abgesichert ist. Also wenn Kinder ausfällig werden, also aus der pädagogischen Ecke gesehen, wenn die halt irgendwelche Söhnen einen Abnormerscheidung zeigen, da sind wir heute sehr überspitzt.
Also zum Beispiel hochbegabt sind, oder?
8, 9-Jähriger, 4, 5 Stunden zu Hause, sitzt an seinem Komp und da rumtutzelt, ja. So musst du dir das vorstellen. Dann fangen die schon an, Helljurist zu werden. Und jetzt geht es halt los. Und je mehr sich verschärft, dann kommen halt diese pädagogischen Untersuchungen. Die Kinder sitzen zu viel, in der Schule 6, 7 Stunden und dann noch mal am Komp. Und dann Sportmangel, dann haben sie halt motorische Fähigkeiten, die fehlen und so weiter. Und da geht es dann los. Und wie gesagt, die Eltern sind natürlich da Helljurist und das wird schon blockiert. Ich meine, ich finde, wir, du hast ja jetzt viel über die Pädagogen gesprochen und ein bisschen angegriffen. Wir stehen halt zwischen Baum und Bord. Auf jeden Fall sind es halt schon moderne Pädagogen, die das auch fördern wollen. Also ich bin halt auch relativ beliebt und mach halt eine ganze Menge und werde auch akzeptiert. Aber das heißt, ich werde halt auch hier bremsen. Und die Bremsen kommen jetzt nicht nur von den Ämtern, sondern kommen auch wirklich stark aus den Eltern aus.
Wie kann man die Eltern eigentlich gleich miterwischen, weil dann das gibt ja diese komische Geschichte mit der EU-Kunde, diesem EU-Papier und den Kinderpornos oder was?
Ja, stimmt. Dazu sollte man vielleicht auch noch was sagen. Und zwar, da geht es jetzt um die Medienkompetenz der Gesellschaft als solchen. Es gab ja jetzt diesen etwas merkwürdigen Zusammenhang, dass es auf der einen Seite die Cybercrime Convention gab, die bestimmte Sachen verbieten wollte. Zum Beispiel Hackerangriffstools und freies Internet. Eine Woche vorher gab es diesen Virus, der in der ganzen Welt Panik gemacht hat. Und einige Wochen vorher gab es eine Sitzung des Justizausschusses der Europäischen Union, wo darüber beraten wurde, wie man dann... Es ging um die gescheiterte Infopol-Initiative, also um die Überwachung innerhalb von Europa. Nicht nur das, was die Amerikaner machen, sondern auch die europäischen Polizeien sollten besser zusammenarbeiten. Und das hat schon mal einen Vorsstoß gegeben, wo dann aber die Datenschützer auf die Barrikaden gegangen sind und wo auch die Leute, die sich daran erinnert haben, dass wir mal Briefe und dreimalige Heimnissatten auf die Barrikaden gegangen sind. Und dann haben sie diese Infopol-Initiative, also offiziell eingestellt, die gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Und dann haben sie aber in dieser EU-Sitzung gesagt, ja, wir werden das jetzt anders machen. Wir werden jetzt diese EZ-Richtlinien, also es gibt jetzt so europäische Telekommunikationsstandardsrichtlinien, die eigentlich genau diese alte Infopol-Richtlinien sind, nur halt mit einem anderen Namen, das heißt jetzt Telekommunikationsstandard. Das klingt alles ein bisschen harmloser. Und wenn es da Probleme mit der öffentlichen Akzeptanz gibt, dann empfehlt die Europäische Union, der Justizausschuss, also die Kommission empfiehlt das ganz offiziell in diesem Papier. Man solle doch einfach in der Öffentlichkeit einige Fälle von Kinderpornografie präsentieren, um die Akzeptanz in der Bevölkerung von Überwachungsmaßnahmen entsprechend zu steigern.
Und sowas ging eben dann nicht, wenn die Leute genau wüssten, wie das da tatsächlich läuft und mit dieser Information umgehen könnten.
Aber das wollen ja die, die solche Empfehlungen rausgeben, verhindern.
Ne, genau, und das heißt, dass mit Medieninkompetenz wird Politik gemacht. Kann man andersrum sagen. Das bringt natürlich auch Geld.
Ja, schau dir den Innenminister an. Wir fragen mal Tillmann.
Erstmal zu meiner Ausgangssituation. Ich bin auf dem Gymnasium, habe dann 9. Klasse Wahlpflicht machen müssen. Entweder Informationstechnischer Grundkurs Kurse Informatik oder eben Französisch. Ich habe mich natürlich für ITG entschieden, denn die dritte Fremdsprache ohne mich. Dann hatten wir eben im ersten Halbjahr VIN-Word. Dort haben wir dann irgendwelche Texte eingegeben, formatiert. Also das übliche sozusagen am zweiten Halbjahr. Was wir jetzt immer noch machen, ist dann To-O-Pascal-Programme. Irgendwelche mathematischen Sachen, Verwaltungs-Sachen und all so ein Krimskram.
Also das heißt Medien waren irgendwie gar nicht Thema bei euch?
Nee, also wir können nach der Stunde ab und zu so ein bisschen Internet, oder auch Vollstunde oder so, je nachdem wie Zeit ist. Und wir haben eben zwei Räume mit glaube ich je 16 Computern. Ja, das ist doch eigentlich schon ganz gut ausgestattet ungefähr. Die Hälfte in einem Raum der Computer, also ein Viertel ungefähr der Computer, sind so drei und vier Sechsnachtziger. Sind zwar dann nicht so toll, aber ein To-of-was-Cup-Programm kann man darauf immer noch schreiben.
Aber wie ist denn das mit dem Internet? Ist das denn im Unterricht, wird das behandelt irgendwie oder?
Nee, das wird nicht behandelt.
Würdest du das wünschen, dass das behandelt wird? Und wenn ja, wie viele Stunden in der Woche könntest du das vorstellen, dass irgendwie wirklich nur über, sag ich mal, Internet und Fernsehen gesprochen wird?
Das würde ich mir in einer anderen Ebene vorstellen. Und zwar in einem Projekt, zum Beispiel zwischen Sozialkunde und Informatik. Sozialkunde, das hatten wir auch mal eben, weiß ich, Quellenarbeit, zum Thema Glaubwürdigkeit und so, der Medien, sekundäre, primäre Quellen, klar. Und dann eben, welche Medien gibt es, wie funktionieren sie? Also da hatten wir mal so ein Projekt mit einem Tagesspiegel, das da gelesen wurde und dann eben kommentiert und Pipapo gemacht wurde.
Aber das Internet war da auch noch nicht Thema?
Also das Internet wurde dann so abgehandelt als elektronische neue Medien. Das war so ein Nebenbei.
Also das Internet gibt es dann irgendwie auch?
Das gibt es auch. Was ich mir wünschen würde, wären eben so Projekte zwischen diesen beiden Fächern, wo dann eben so technische Grundlagen dann geklärt werden. Also was Eke da gesagt hat, fünfte, sechste Klasse sollte man so eine Sachen und Grundlagen behandeln, finde ich ein bisschen übertrieben, denn da fehlen ja doch schon so einige naturwissenschaftliche Hintergrunde. Weiß ich irgendwie binäres Themen, was ist, wie funktioniert eine Bildröhre, wie fließt Strom, was ein Elektron, was ein Magnet und so.
Also tief soll das da eigentlich noch nicht gehen in der sechsten Klasse.
Ja, also da würde ich mir wünschen, dass da erstmal so die Inhalte geklärt werden.
Das ist ein interessanter Ansatz. Du würdest also erst schon mit den Inhalten anfangen, also mit der Technik.
Ja, also bei der Technik kann man dann wirklich erst ins Detail gehen, wenn man in Physik und so und Mathe...
Na ja, aber die Frage ist, du hast natürlich insofern Recht, dass ab der fünften, sechsten Klasse einen Fernsehapparat können die alle schon bedienen. Da brauchen wir nicht drüber reden.
Ja, aber sie wissen nicht, wie der funktioniert.
Ja, aber das mussten wir ja auch nicht wissen, um den Klohäuschenbenutzer einen Fernsehapparat zu bedienen. Das ist eben der Unterschied.
Wobei, wie ein Fernseher funktioniert, ist ja das eine. Das heißt, du schaltest ihn nur wie ein oder so. Das sind also die technischen Grundlagen, also irgendwie mit Kathodenstrahl und sowas. Aber wie Fernsehen funktioniert, das ist ja noch wieder eine andere Sache. Das heißt, wie es produziert wird und warum vor allem auch.
Ja, und da würde ich eben erst die Hinterwunde klären. Wie funktioniert das mit Werbung, wie funktioniert das mit Sendungen?
Ja, vor allen Dingen, dass ein Schnitt eigentlich die Geschichte erzählt. Also es ist nicht der Film oder das Drehbuch, sondern der Schnitt ist es, der hinterher die Geschichte erzählt.
Das wäre sicherlich etwas, was man... Da würde ich auch dann vielleicht mal klären, wie kam es dazu, den Computern, also zu den ersten Schritten zur großen Kommunikation, also die Entwicklung der Schrift, dann vielleicht zum Rose-Alphabet und dann irgendwie die ersten Rechenmaschinen, die dann irgendwie mechanisch irgendwie Aufgaben nüten konnten, die von hochkleveren Leuten in vergangenen Jahrhunderten gemacht wurden und dann eben auch die PC-Entwicklung bis heute.
Das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen Technikgeschichte.
Ja, Technikgeschichte.
Wobei man dann auch sehr schön darüber diskutieren kann, wofür wir denn überhaupt Computer brauchen. Ja, oder speziell wofür, und wofür ist eben vielleicht besser, erstmal eben kein Computer zu nehmen.
Ja, aber um sich zu bewegen beispielsweise, um Sport zu treiben, ist ein Computer irgendwie hinderlich.
Sport zu treiben ist ein Computer hinderlich. Ich glaube, wir haben Leute schon Erfindungen gemacht irgendwie.
Ja, da gibt es doch demnächst...
Ich meine, die wollen uns jetzt sogar schon den Sex abnehmen.
Also, Sex soll jetzt irgendwie auch durch den Computer ersetzt werden, wenn es nach den Leuten geht.
Weil er auch ganz schön macht.
Ich glaube, das bringt es nicht so ganz. Also, Leute sollten wirklich Sport treiben, weil Fußball gibt es ja hier in Deutschland zu genüge. Zum Beispiel gibt es auch noch andere Sportarten und so.
Töne man, wir nehmen mal noch jemand anderen ran.
Schönen Dank erstmal.
Danke dir, macht's gut. Lehrer hat sich bis jetzt keiner gemeldet.
Hallöchen.
Du willst noch mal über ITG abkotzen, aber ich würde das verstehen. Was hast du nicht mehr zu tun, haben wir lang genug gemacht. Was kann man besser machen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Zum Beispiel das Unterrichtsfach, was du da einführen wolltest jetzt in der fünften Klasse.
Ich weiß nicht, ich wäre eigentlich nicht so ganz dafür. Weil ich denke, ich weiß nicht ganz. Vielleicht bin ich auch so ein bisschen abgeschreckt durch ITG. Also was wir da abziehen, das ist echt furchtbar. Wir machen Aufgaben, zum Beispiel, dass wir da Texte, alles zusammengeschrieben, die ganzen Wörter und wir müssen da die Lehrzeichen setzen. So ein blödes Zeug.
Du solltest jetzt aber nicht über ITG abkotzen, sondern sagen, was man besser machen kann.
Genau, das muss konstruktiv sein.
Also ich würde eigentlich gleich damit anfangen, dass man von Anfang an gleich programmieren sollte.
Hallo für alle?
Ist das denn ernst?
Ja, eigentlich, ich würde damit schon mal so...
Wozu müssen bitte alle programmieren? Also ich meine, jemand interessiert sich für Literatur, der muss nicht programmieren können.
Nee, aber ich denke auch, dass man das freiwillig machen sollte, dass man halt, die Leute, die sich dafür interessieren, die sollten das halt schon mal machen und...
Ja klar, aber wir reden jetzt hier von einem Fach, wo wir denken, das sollte eigentlich jeder, und zwar egal, ob er sich für Computer interessiert oder nicht, weil das kannst du dir heute, wenn du irgendwie irgendwann mal erwachsen wirst oder was auch immer, du kannst das ja nicht mehr aussuchen, ob du mit Computern zu tun hast oder nicht. Jeder hat heute mit Computern zu tun.
Ja klar, dann sollte man halt erstmal lernen, mit dem Betriebssystem umzugehen. Das ist auf jeden Fall, dass man die Kinder halt in der fünften Klasse so dahinsetzt und dass sie dann da halt erstmal so ein bisschen...
Mit dem Betriebssystem, von welchem berätest du dann?
Also ich würde jetzt zum Beispiel, ich würde sagen Linux. Mit Linux wird man eigentlich bei Windows. Ich denke mal, Linux ist die Zukunft, deswegen...
Ja gut, aber die Frage ist halt, meine abgesehenen von der Handhabe eines Betriebssystems, der Anspruch, allen das Programmieren beizubringen, der würde uns dann glaube ich wieder zu weit gehen, weil wir sagen, wir wollen nicht aus der ganzen Menschheit Computerfix machen.
Das würde ich auch gar nicht wissen wie das geht. Also das würde ich nie im Leben wissen wollen.
Vor allem da kriegst du auch bei den Pädagogen, da wird es ziemlich schwierig.
Ich glaube auch, dass du die Leute damit mehr abschreckst, als du den Computer begeisterst. Das ist ja das, was der ITG-Unterricht auch oftmals macht.
Abschrecken.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings. Ich denke auch erstmal, dass man richtiges Personal einsetzen sollte. Unser Lehrer sagt zum Beispiel, zum Power-Knopf sagt der Pover-Knopf.
Das ist ja nun ein kleinerer Mangel, aber wo willst du dieses kompetente Personal herkriegen?
Ich denke zum Beispiel, dass man Informatik-Studenten nach der Ausbildung vielleicht da auch reinholen könnte. Also die gerade frisch jung noch sind, das ist die noch richtig gut.
Was Informatik ist, ist dir klar, dass Informatik-Studenten größtenteils Theorie behandeln, und dass sie der Google-Kenn-Klan haben und von Internet, wenn sie Glück hatten.
Und wenn, dann kann die Schule niemals so viel zahlen, dass sich die Leute auch nur umgedreht zu erablassen würden, um in der Schule aufzutauchen.
Ja, das ist extrem ambitioniert sein.
Also unsere Schulen zum Beispiel, ich finde, die Schulen geben auch für ganz andere, für viel zu viele andere Sachen Geld aus, anstatt sie mal für das Geld anständig investieren würden. Also zum Beispiel wir, wir kriegen Feuerschutz-Türen in der Schule, für die aus Holz sind. Die brauchen wir gar nicht.
Ja gut, aber das könnten auch irgendwelche gesetzlichen Vorschlüften sein. An der Stelle ist dann nicht die Schule schuld, sondern irgendwie die übergeordnete Instanz, die es eventuell wichtiger findet, euch vor einem Rand zu bewahren, als vor der Unkenntnis des Internets.
Ja, also ich schulde trotzdem erstmal, dass man die Kinder da halt so hinsetzt und erstmal so ein drittes, viertes Jahr oder so, dass sie halt erstmal so ein bisschen mit dem Betriebssystem ein bisschen selber rumspielen sollten und so. Und dann halt so ein etwas tiefer, naja...
Ja, vielleicht für die, die es interessieren.
Genau, also dass man dann halt sagt, nach einem halben Schuljahr oder so, okay, die, die jetzt weitermachen wollen, die sollen weitermachen, weil die anderen, die machen halt so einen kleinen Grundkurs weiter, dass sie mit Wirk sind, wird und all sowas umgehen.
Wobei das ja alles wirklich Technikkompetenz ist, ne? Da geht es ja nicht um die Inhalte, das heißt, wie kommt die Werbung in die Suchmaschine und so eine Geschichte?
Wie kommt die Werbung in die Suchmaschine?
Wie kommt die Suchmaschine in die Werbung?
Genau, wir haben hier vielleicht jemanden dran, der dieses Unterrichtsproblem oder Dilemma lösen kann. Ich danke für deine Antwort.
Hallo, Jean. Ja, hallo.
Du bist IT-Berater, bist du INDER?
Ich muss nicht extra das Land wechseln. Ja, ich rufe fast zwei Lagunen an. Einmal, weil ich in der Entry-Branche arbeite. Zum anderen, weil meine Eltern beide Lehrer waren. Ja, ich bin ein bisschen pädagogisch vorgeschädigt. Was mir jetzt sehr aufgefallen ist, ist, dass der Interessenkonflikt, den die Schüler da haben, die kommen da also rein. Und sie interessieren sich voll für ein Thema und haben jetzt zu Hause schon aus Interesse einfach umgespielt und erwarten automatisch, dass ihre Lehrer genauso kompetent sind auf dem Gebiet. Das ist natürlich geht gar nicht, so zu glauben. Weil die Leute, die jetzt Lehrer werden und den Beruf ausüben, die haben diese Interessenlagen meistens überhaupt nicht.
Aber es ist ihr Job, die zu haben.
Ja, genau. Ich glaube, der Zwang einfach bei den Lehrern ist, was ich so festgestellt habe, ist ein ganz anderer. Die haben diesen Zwang einfach nicht.
Also wenn ich als Berater hingehe und sage, mich interessiert das nicht.
Ist zwar mein Job, aber das interessiert mich nicht, da bin ich innerhalb von einem Jahr arbeitslos. Also bei meinen Eltern und so, die konnten sich halt immer ziemlich darauf ausruhen, dass sie es nicht unbedingt wissen mussten.
Ja, aber das ist natürlich tatsächlich...
Das ist aber ein Systemmangel und ich denke, das liegt irgendwie am Beamtenstatus.
Moment, Moment, ich habe aber jetzt noch mal kurz eine Frage. Kann ich deine Theorie so interpretieren, dass du also sagst, dass es sogar so ist, dass Leute, die heute nichts mit Computern zu tun haben wollen, die werden Lehrer?
Ähm, ich habe Elektrotechnik studiert, ja. Die Leute, die es nicht geschaffen haben, die rausgeflogen sind, sind Berufsschullehrer geworden.
Ja, das stimmt. Darüber könnte ich auch irgendwie viele Geschichten erzählen. Ich hatte mal ein elektrotechnisches Fach zwischen Physik und Maschinenbau. Ein Lehrer hat uns versucht, etwas von Hochschaltanlagen zu erzählen. Er hat dann eine ganz wilde Geschichte erzählt. Ja, wenn man die Transformatorenberechnung falsch macht, können da russische Dinge passieren. Dann erzählt er eine Geschichte, dass bei Siemens auf dem Werksgelände. Dann hat uns ein Lehrer erzählt, dass der Mensch genau deswegen bei Siemens rausgeflogen ist, weil er das Projekt verantwortlich war.
Darf ich kurz unterbrechen? Wir haben einen Lehrer am Telefon.
Andersrum haben wir bei uns jemanden in der Firma, der war Lehrer und ist Hieberater geworden.
Wegen besseren Verdienst?
Ich glaube nicht. Ja, weil er keinen Bock auf Fühler hatte. Weil ihm das zu nervig war.
Das ist aber gemein.
Jetzt hören wir mal den Lehrer.
Ja, Jean, vielen Dank. Der einzig mutige Lehrer an diesem Abend in Berlin und Brandenburg.
Herr Uschner, schönen guten Abend.
Also ich sitze gerade an den Stundenvorbereitungen für morgen früh für meine Schüler.
Sie kriegen was um die Spannende.
Und sitze jetzt am Computer und habe zufällig hier mit so einem ganz kleinen Radio, was ich hier über meinem Monitor habe, habe ich die Sendung verfolgt. Und da sind natürlich viele Fragen aufgeworfen worden, wo ich der Meinung bin. Die müsste man eigentlich ein bisschen ordnen, Medien und das Interesse der Lehrer, das Interesse der Schüler. Was im Vordergrund steht, wenn ihr also über das Thema diskutiert und Lehrer in die Pfanne haut oder auch nicht in die Pfanne haut. Der Lehrer ist ein Angestellter und das heißt, der Lehrer muss eigentlich laut Lehrplan arbeiten. Das, was also von euch gesagt wird und gefordert wird, müssen erst mal die Kultusminister umsetzen.
Ja, aber ich kann mich doch nicht einfach auf meinen Vorgesetzten zurücklehnen und sagen, nö, mein Vorgesetzter will das nicht, ich mach das nicht. Ich hab doch auch eine Verantwortung, ich hab doch auch in meinem Beruf hier eine Verantwortung.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Und diese Verantwortung versuche ich mit allen Mitteln wahrzunehmen. Und ich finde, dass gerade Lehrer, die Pflicht haben, diese Verantwortung ebenfalls wahrzunehmen. Und genau das scheinen sie nicht zu tun.
Ja, bloß wo sollen die Lehrer diese Pflicht wahrnehmen? Sie haben keinen Einfluss auf die Lehrpläne.
Was sie erfordern, ist ein extra Schulfach, dass sich auch kein Lehrer eigentlich damit rausreden kann. Sozusagen, bei mir im Fach ist da kein Platz für.
Wollen wir, bevor wir es irgendwie, wir müssen gleich das Kurzinfo machen. Bleiben Sie so lange dran oder sollen wir Sie zurückrufen?
Nee, also ich wüsste dann irgendwie, ich wüsste dann in die Haie. Kurzen oder etwas. Was man natürlich, wo man Medien und Informatik vorantreiben könnte, wäre durch interessante Projekte, die Jugendliche angreifen. Das wäre eine interessante Sache.
Also angreifen im Sinne von provozieren?
Jawohl.
Wo sie Interesse zeigen, Neigungen zeigen. Also in der fünften Klasse Informatik machen ist nisch.
Nee, das haben wir auch nicht gesagt.
Nein, der eine Anrufer meinte das nicht. Das kann nicht funktionieren. Aber die Schüler, unsere Jugendlichen angreifen mit interessanten Projekten. Dort müssen die Lehrer ihre Verantwortung suchen, indem sie gemeinsam aus den verschiedenen Fächern sich zusammentun und die Schüler begeistern und die Informatik als Mittel benutzen, um also Wissen, Medien und so weiter an sich anzueignen. Und das letzte zu dem Problem, Porno, was ihr dort gesagt habt, das wird und kann immer passieren. Wichtig ist, dass jemand dabei ist, der Ansprechpartner ist.
Ja klar, aber auch dann möglicherweise nicht einfach nur einen Schreikampf kriegt, sondern auch eine vollständige deutsche Setze reden kann, nachdem er irgendwie Sex mit Tieren auf dem Bildschirm gesehen hat. Da hab ich eben wie gesagt eine Pädagogin Marja Trafen und die konnte das gar nicht mehr.
Herr Uschner, was wäre Ihr Vorschlag, Ihre Kollegen zu motivieren, dann vielleicht auch mal den einen oder anderen Computer einzuschalten und sich damit zu beschäftigen?
Ja, ich motiviere seit fünf Jahren meine Kollegen. Ich bin Moderator in Potsdam und mache Lehrgänge aller Art und vor allen Dingen vertrete ich ihm die Strecke, den Lehrern zu zeigen, dass es überhaupt nicht wesentlich ist, zu wissen, wie ein Computer oder wie ein Fernseher funktioniert. Ich muss mit dem Gerät umgehen können, sinnvoll umgehen können und das einsetzen. Ich muss mir noch die Zeit suchen, damit ich Sport treiben kann.
Richtig. Ich muss auch keinen Motor auseinandernehmen können, um Auto zu fahren.
Genau.
Oder dieses Studio reparieren.
Richtig. Bin ich auch der Meinung. Ich muss das Medium nutzen. Ich muss diese Technik nutzen. Und die Fähigkeit besitzen, keine Angst davor haben. Und das Wesentliche ist, man hat natürlich die Lehrer vergessen bei der Fortbildung, sie müssen jetzt befähigt werden, die Angst zu verlieren, die die Kinder, die Jugendlichen nicht haben. Ich sage das immer, die gehen ganz brutal an die Maschine ran, schalten die ein, wenn sie abstürzen. Ich habe ja Zeit. Die haben erwachsen natürlich nicht. Sie haben einen eng bemessenen Zeitraum und da muss die Maschine funktionieren.
Vielen Dank. Nachrichten.
Ich wünsche Ihnen noch eine schöne Diskussionsrunde, einen schönen Abend und gute Nacht.
Und vielen Dank für Ihren Spaß morgen am Unterricht.
Tja Irina, no pain, no gain würde ich sagen und außerdem würde ich sagen 0 Uhr 33.
Kurz Info, Ferifpoker bei den Schlichtungsverhandlungen für den öffentlichen Dienst zeichnet sich bislang noch keine Einigung ab. Es werde weiter heftig um einen Kompromiss gerungen, hieß es am späten Abend. Unklar ist nach wie vor, ob die Kernprobleme, Zusatzversorgung, Lohnerhöhung und Ostangleichung gelöst werden können. Bildungsoffensive, dafür haben sich in Brandenburg Vertreter von Hochschulen und Wirtschaftsverbänden stark gemacht. Sie forderten von der Landesregierung in den nächsten vier Jahren 380 Millionen Mark zusätzlich. Nur so könne Brandenburg im internationalen Konkurrenzkampf bestehen. Studentendemo, mehr als 3000 Menschen haben in der serbischen Stadt Nis, gegen den jugoslawischen Präsident Milošević protestiert. Sie forderten die Regierung auf, ihre Repressionen gegen Oppositionsanhänger und unabhängige Medien einzustellen. Kritik, das Bundeskartellamt hat die fünf großen Mineralölkonzerne wegen des Preiskriegs zulasten freier Tankstellen abgemahnt. Beanscheidet wurde, dass die Konzerne das Benzin an ihren eigenen Zapfsäulen billiger verkaufen als an freie Tankstellenbetreiber. Fußball. Real Madrid hat die Champions League gewonnen. Real bezwang am Abend im Finale in Paris in FC Valencia 3-0. Für Madrid war es bereits der achte Erfolg im Wettbewerb der Landesmannschaft. Die Nacht ist trocken, 14 bis 11 Grad. Am Tag dann Regenschauer, 18 bis 24 Grad.
Ein Kurzinsummit, Irina Gramovsky, um 0.35 Uhr.
Vielen Dank. Morgen Abend um 22 Uhr im Blue Moon auf Ritz.
Hallo liebe Hörerinnen und, doch ich sag mal Hörerinnen, genau. Viele von euch wünschen sich ab und an mal mit ihrem Lieblingsmoderator ein bisschen zu kuscheln, zu schmusen oder sich einfach mit ihm von Auge zu Auge zu unterhalten oder ihm nur auf die Fresse zu hauen und all das könnt ihr denn. Der Michi Balzer und ich, wir werden uns nach Berlin Mitte begeben von 22 bis 1 Uhr. Der Blue Moon von der Straße und dann könntet ihr den Michi Balzer auf die Schnauze hauen und den Rest mit mir machen kurz um Radio zum Anfassen, aber nur mit Gummi.
Live aus Berlin Mitte vor den hackischen Höfen. Der Blue Moon mit Tommy Wosch und Michi Balzer.
Morgen Abend auf Ritz.
Und jetzt auf Ritz im Chaosradio Nummer 50 noch ein bisschen Musik von Otaku.
Nebenbei bemerkt, die Musik verdanken wir dir DJ Okatou, der... Otaku, richtig. Das ist irgendwie der japanische Begriff für Hacker. Der trotz einer totalen Cinchkabel frisst, die Technik ist Schuldkatastrophe, sich größte Mühe an den Plattentellern gibt und wer den mal außerhalb hören will, der könnte zum Beispiel morgen Abend im Kato in Kreuzberg auf der Anti-Expo-Party oder am 2. Juni in der Sea-Base in der Ofanienburger 2 das da aufsuchen. Hallo.
Du rufst aus Bayern an?
Ja.
Wie ist denn das da? Da seid ihr doch alle super ausgebildet, ihr seid das Silicon Valley Europas.
Naja, wollen wir das mal nicht übertreiben.
Also, was ist die Wahrheit?
Ihr unterhaltet euch die ganze Zeit, wie man das Internet nutzen kann, in der Schule.
Zum Beispiel die besten Wege.
Aber ich finde, man sollte ansprechen, dass es einfach relativ, also Schwierigkeiten gibt, dass das überhaupt nutzbar wird. Weil ich hab das gesehen, bei meiner Schule, da kamen vor circa drei Jahren nagelneue Computer, super Einrichtung, alles top. Und es war circa ein Jahr lang fast kein Schüler in dem Raum.
Warum? Haben die die Schüler nicht reingeschlossen?
Nein, es war einfach kein Lehrer da, der in der Lage war, das zu betreuen. Der in der Lage war, das einzurichten und das auf dem Laufenden zu halten.
Ja, aber da wären noch sicherlich Schüler da gewesen.
Ja, unter anderem ich. Wir haben uns angeboten. Aber es waren Lehrer einfach nicht bereit, Schüler da hinzulassen.
Klar, es ist ja auch eine teure Technik und man weiß ja nicht, was sie da veranstalten.
Bis dann irgendwann ein Lehrer mal die Initiative ergriffen hat, ich hab dann die letzten zwei Jahre das System administriert. Erfolgreich. Es lief nie besser. Und es gab dann auch zum Beispiel einmal in der Woche eine Stunde für Oberstufe, der Zugang frei war, der von Schülern unter anderem mir eben auch kontrolliert wurde und überprüft wurde. Und es wurde super angenommen. Also wenn man zum Beispiel das auch nutzt, dass Schüler sich integrieren können, Arbeitsgruppen machen, wo Schüler Schüler helfen, dann wird es viel mehr angenommen, wie wenn Lehrer und Schüler da was machen. Vor allem, weil eben auch an meiner Schule die Kompetenz in dem Bereich wahnsinnig gering ist.
Was könntest du dir denn vorstellen, wir haben ja eben gerade mit einem Lehrer diskutiert und der hat ja gesagt, das Problem ist, dass es irgendwie in den Lehrplänen, die ja vom Kultusministerium ist, eben nicht vorgesehen ist, blablabla, und dass deswegen eben die Lehrer gar nicht die Zeit haben, weil die eben nur sich auf die Fächer vorbereiten können, für die sie auch offiziell Lehrplanzeit haben, sich damit auseinandersetzen. Meinst du denn, es wäre möglicherweise eine Methode, dass man den Kultusministerien nicht sagt, ok, ihr müsst jetzt den Lehrern Internet beibringen, sondern erlaubt den Lehrern einfach mal ein Zeitbudget von den Schülern etwas zu lernen und in diesem Fall etwas, was die Schüler besser können, nämlich mit diesem Medium umzugehen?
Wäre sicher eine gute Sache. Vor allem, weil an jeder Schule Schüler sind, die sich besser auskennen in der Beziehung als Lehrer.
Aber dabei geht es doch jetzt wieder eigentlich nur um die Technik, oder?
Nicht unbedingt, auch mit dem Umgang.
Ja, aber das, was dahinter steckt, also diese medienkritischen Sachen, kann sowas von den Schülern auch kommen?
Okay, das vielleicht weniger. Das pädagogische in diesem Unterricht, das kommt nicht von den Schülern. Sondern allein der Umgang, dass sich jemand da hinsetzt und holt seine E-Mails ab, das können Schüler vermitteln. Bei uns gab es eben den Unterricht, es gab eine Stunde, da konnten Schüler der Oberstufe da rein, E-Mails schreiben, E-Mails einrichten usw. Es wurde von uns betreut, wir haben es unterstützt. Danach konnten die damit umgehen. Das allein ist schon wahnsinnig schwer, dass die Leute damit umgehen können. Lehrer, die setzen die Leute hin. Es gab Lehrer, die haben sich darauf vorbereitet. Die haben ihre Sachen angeschaut, was sie auch mit den Schülern anschauen wollen. Aber es gab auch Lehrer, die haben einfach damit ihre Zeit gutgeschlagen. Eine Stunde rumgebracht, um ihren Aufwand gering zu halten. Und da muss was getan werden. Man hat so viele Möglichkeiten vom System her, Sachen zu speichern oder vorauszuladen oder was auch immer. Und dass sowas auch genutzt wird. Und ein Lehrer, der von der Technik kein Verständnis hat, wie was funktioniert, im groben Zug wenigstens, der kann auch nicht Schülern was vermitteln, wenn es auch Inhalte sind. Er hat Angst. Wenn einem Lehrer die Angst genommen wird, dann kann er damit umgehen. Aber das ist das Problem.
Das ist sein Job, keine Angst zu haben.
Die werden dafür bezahlt.
Wenn ich hier Mist baue, dann faltet mich mein Chef morgen zusammen. Was eigentlich recht häufig passiert.
Ein Deutschlehrer, der 40 Jahre lang seine Gedichte interpretiert hat. Er kann sich heute Morgen an einen Computer setzen und in der Klasse die Gedichtsinterpretation im Internet zeigen.
Da soll er in Rente gehen?
Ja, genau. Ich appelliere an Wörtern, die er hört, auf Anfragen. Sie setzen sich bewusst mit dem Medium nicht auseinander. Sie haben ihre alte Adler-Schreibmaschine und mehr wollen sie nicht. Mehr machen sie nicht. Ganz bewusst.
Dann ist aber der Gesetzgeber doch gefordert, dass er genau diesen Leuten den Geldhahn abdreht.
Aber was will der Gesetzgeber da machen? Der Mann ist 50 Jahre oder 55? Was will er machen?
Entweder soll er ihn in eine Umschulung schicken. Wahrscheinlich wäre es damit getan, wenn man sagt, Lehrer dürfen immer nur 5 Jahre im Lehrbetrieb sein. Danach müssen sie erst mal 5 Jahre irgendwie mit der selber lernen.
Im Moment sind es einfach Beamte, die in ihrem Job sind. Und die bringen es nicht so schnell raus. Die können nach ihren 20 Jahren gutem Dienst 10 Jahre lang totalen Mist bauen. Und verlieren den Job nicht.
Die bleiben dann noch ein paar Jahre krank, weil sie ja irgendwie überarbeitet sind mit 52.
Aber der Sympathische, den ich mal kennengelernt habe, hat es darauf angelegt, frühpensioniert zu werden. Und hat sich also absichtlich, und das hat er auch allen gesagt, dass er sich total danebenbinden. Das war schon wieder lustig.
Es gibt immer noch Auffälle.
Aber es gibt auch Leute, die wollen mit geringstem Aufwand ihre Pension ins Alter retten. Und die sind in keinem Fall bereit, einem Schüler etwas zu vermitteln. Sie sind nicht mehr in der Lage, weil ihnen die Kraft dazu fehlt.
Wobei ich dann aber auch nicht verstehe, dass nicht die Lehrer hingehen, die tatsächlich mit Ambitionen an ihrem Beruf hängen und genau diesen Brüdern in den Arsch treten. Weil es gibt ja Mittel und Wege, jemandem auf den Sack zu gehen, wenn man das möchte.
Ja, die gibt es. Aber ich sehe das bei uns, das ganze Lehrkommunikium, es ist teilweise verhasst und teilweise möchte eine an die andere. Und ich selber habe auch schon probiert, über den Elternbeirat bei diversen Lehrern mal Vollunterhinter zu machen. Es klappt zwei Wochen lang. Zwei Wochen lang, dann geht was. Dann ist wieder der alte Trott da.
Ja, dann mangelt es an Schneid und Ehre und Anstrengung.
Aber bei uns hat Schneid, es wurde heuer der Direktor gemacht.
Beispiel, wir haben jetzt einen neuen Direktor. Jung, mit Elan, der bringt eine Energie in diese Schule, was der alte Direktor in den letzten zehn Jahren runtergewirtschaftet hat. Und da merkt man auch irgendwo Erneuerungen, die einfach öfter stattfinden muss in den Schulen. Es wird damit getan, dass ab und zu mal ein neuer Referentar kommt. Es muss öfter was geschehen. Wenn ein Direktor nach zehn Jahren lang in dieser Schule ist oder auch Lehrer, ein Lehrer zehn Jahre, gewöhnt er sich dran. Wenn er aber Lehrer wechseln muss nach zehn Jahren oder fünf Jahren, dann muss er sich neu beweisen in der Schule. Dann muss er seine Leistung bringen. Und dann kann er sich nicht auf seinen Pfahl dahinter docken. Das wäre vielleicht auch noch ein Ansatz.
Okay, das ist etwas grundsätzlicher.
In so konventionellen Unterrichtsfaechern ist es ja auch so, dass eigentlich gar nicht die Notwendigkeit besteht, sich vorzubilden und auf dem Stand Dinge zu bleiben. Weil in Deutsch ändert sich nun mal über 40 Jahre nicht so furchtbar viel. Und genauso bin ich in Chemie. Jedenfalls nicht in dem Rahmen, in dem Unterricht gelehrt wird.
Ich meine, ob da jetzt ein eigenes Unterrichtsfach hier muss, darüber kann man streiten.
Das wollten wir eigentlich machen, Kinder.
Ja, aber ich will nicht der Meinung, ein eigenes Unterrichtsfach muss her. Ich bin der Meinung, dass das Internet wahnsinnig gut in jedes Unterrichtsfach integriert werden kann.
Ja, aber dazu müssen doch die Kinder erstmal die Grundlagen haben. Weil es ist nicht haltbar, dass man irgendwie im Fremdsprachenunterricht das Internet benutzen will und dann die ersten Mal zwei Stunden damit verbringt, den Kindern beizubringen, wie sie überhaupt die Technik benutzen. Das kann man einfach niemandem verkaufen und das ist nicht zumutbar.
Vor allem der kritische Umgang mit dem Medium. Der ist das Wichtige und das können eigentlich die Fächer kaum leisten. Wenn sie halt im Deutschunterricht damit umgehen sollen, dann können sie nicht halt noch nebenbei Stunden lang über das Medium als solches diskutieren. Sie sollen es einfach ganz normal benutzen und irgendwie aber auch mit offenen Augen benutzen.
Das ist Argument, das stimmt. Dann müsste man eben in den unteren Klassenstufen das machen.
Ja, genau, das war ja unser Konzept. Das wird kommen müssen, genau. Aber im Moment gibt es zumindest uns noch keine bekannte Initiative, die das mal tatsächlich dann auch macht. Ich meine, es gibt natürlich immer auf lokaler Ebene Leute, die scheißen einfach auf die Lehrthemen und die machen die richtigen Sachen. Keine Frage.
Du kannst auch nicht als Lehrer irgendwie ein ganzes Jahr lang nur jetzt irgendwie Medien behandeln.
Nee, ist schon richtig. Da gibt es dann irgendwie noch...
Es gibt Lehrer, die sich einfach nicht mehr einsetzen, die das auch in Klassen des beibringen wollen. Es gibt die, die meiden. Aber bis dessen Kultusministerium abgesegnet wird, das ist auch das Problem. Und da wird das einfach die Reaktionsgeschwindigkeit momentan...
Ich klinge da vielleicht ein bisschen dogmatisch, aber ich verlange dann vom Lehrer, dass er sich darüber hinweg setzt. Der ist in der Lage, seinen Lehrplan einzuhalten und darüber hinaus Dinge zu tun. Ansonsten würden nämlich nicht Lehrer... Also ich kann nur von meiner eigenen Schule reden. Da gibt es einen Sportdeutschlehrer, der permanent mit irgendwelchen Nachmittags-AGs irgendwohin Skifahren geht, irgendwas macht und dit macht und jenes macht und eine Theater-AG macht und eine Höhe-AG und eine Hot-AG. Und es wird permanent weggefahren, in Urlaub gefahren, Späßchen. So, wenn diese Brüder diese Energie da reinbringen würden oder da investieren würden, wo Leute diese Energie brauchen, wo Leute nämlich ausgebildet werden müssen und wirklich kompetent gemacht werden müssen, dann sähe unsere Welt, glaube ich, ein bisschen besser aus. Aber nein, wir fahren Ski. Und das finde ich einfach ein Unding.
Einen Lehrer zu finden, der bereit ist, Freizeit und Energie zu opfern.
Ich kenne welche.
Ja, ich kenne auch.
Ich kenne eine, ich kenne zwei.
Ja, das ist das Problem.
Wir haben mit 30 Lehrer an der Schule und wenn dann zwei Lehrer Energie bringen und andere Lehrer. Wir haben versucht, einen Nachmittagskurs Informatik auf die Beine zu stellen. Und sind auf die Suche nach einem Lehrer gegangen, der bereit ist zu machen. Wenn man sich dann anhören muss, dass ein Lehrer nicht bereit ist, seine Freizeit oder seine Zeit zu opfern für sowas. Es geht von seiner Zeit weg. Dann verliert man noch den Spaß.
Wo man mit einem Korrekturschema Standardklassenarbeiten korrigieren kann, da geht dann irgendwas von seiner Zeit ab. Aber das können wir glaube ich auch endlos plattweisen. Kylian, du bist nicht der letzte Hörer der heutigen Sendung. Ich danke für deinen Anruf. Der letzte ist vermutlich Sascha.
Ich weiß nicht jetzt ein Schlusswort.
Ja, gib uns ein Schlusswort.
Ich habe jetzt nur kurz die Diskussion verfolgt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon angesprochen habt. Ich habe jetzt eine lange Zeit in Ostwestfalen da unten. Und die machen das eigentlich so mit Schulen, die heulen externe Firmen an. Da gibt es so die Future Kids. So eine Firma, die dann hingeht und den Leuten an Schulen, auch im privaten Bereich, eben den Kids zuerst mal zeigt, wie man an Computer umgeht. Wie man mit dem Computer umgeht, mit den simplen Sachen. Und es gibt auch ein Projekt, wo die dann eben an Schulen auch den Lehrern das beibringen. Wie nun die Lehrer motiviert sind oder nicht, ist eine andere Geschichte. Ich habe dann eben auch mal, ich habe mal so eine Stunde teilgenommen, habe ich festgestellt, dass die Lehrer, also es war schon schwierig, dass sie überhaupt mit einer Maus umgehen konnten. Also um das mal so zu sagen. Und ich meine, man kann jetzt darüber diskutieren, ob die Lehrer motiviert sind oder nicht. Ich meine, es ist genau die Generation, die irgendwie froh ist, wenn sie überhaupt den Computer einschalten kann. Und alles andere ergibt sich. Und ich meine, so ein junger motivierter Lehrer, okay, der kann vielleicht eher mit dem Computer umgehen. Aber ich denke mir, die Lehrer haben ganz was anderes im Kopf, als sich jetzt um Näherzahlen zu kümmern. Die sind halt froh, wenn sie heil aus dem Unterricht rauskommen.
Na ja, an den Barschulen ist das sicherlich richtig.
Zu der Sache mit den Fünfen wollte ich noch mal was sagen. Es war als Übergangslösung ganz prima, weil da wenigstens was passiert. Aber auf lange Sicht ist das doch eigentlich eher die Verantwortung des Staates, aus der er sich unter Umständen, wenn sich das ausbreitet, immer mehr raussteht. Und mit dem Argument, es funktioniert ja, und wir müssen uns ja nicht kümmern.
Genau, die Horrorvision wäre dann irgendwie, ja die Summa Microsoft bringt den Schülern bei, die Telekom-Mutter-Betriebung funktioniert. Oder die Telekom schickt Leute aus, die den Leuten beibringen, wie man es hier online bedient, aber natürlich nicht, wie man es Internet bedient.
Ich meine, das gibt mich dir recht, diese Vision ist gar nicht so weit hergeholt. Ich meine, das macht ja Bill Gates schon in der dritten Welt.
Ja, das ist auch in Amerika, aber nicht in Mexiko. Amerika zählt offiziell noch nicht zur dritten Welt, auch wenn so ein Bildungsniveau anmählich in die Richtung geht.
Da haben sie Telefon.
Ich kenne so ein Projekt in der dritten Welt, wo Bill Gates dann eben auch bereit war, Sachspenden zu äußern.
Ja, aber natürlich ist er dann bereit, Sachspenden zu äußern. Ich meine, der wäre schön blöd, wenn er da nicht Werbematerial irgendwie an Präsidenten und Regierungschefs verteilen würde.
Naja, ich meine, gut, vielleicht wird er irgendwann mal entdecken, dass er in Deutschland damit ganz gut ankommen würde. Und das ist eine Horrorvision.
Du, das hat er doch schon entdeckt. Ich meine, guck dir noch mal das Teil an. Ist das ein Paradebeispiel?
Der hat ja mehr oder weniger den Minister da gekauft. Da gibt es ja schon die eine oder andere Geschichte. Aber gut, wir wollen jetzt über Horrorvision, glaube ich, nicht unbedingt, also ich wollte die Sendung ungern mit Horrorvision ausklingen lassen, muss ich gestehen. Weil, die kriege ich irgendwie morgen früh, wenn ich mich wieder mit dem wirklichen Leben auseinanderlässe.
Was lässt dich so sicher sein, dass das morgen das richtige Leben ist?
Siehst du die rote oder die blaue?
Ja, ich bin da ein Fan von der roten, aber okay.
Sascha, gute Nacht.
Ich euch auch. Du uns auch.
Du auch.
Ja, also, ich dachte, wir könnten das Ganze ja nochmal mit einer anderen Vision ausklingen lassen. Nehmen wir mal an, ich fand es gut, wir haben auch mal ein Problem. Aber das wird jetzt im Moment so dargestellt, als könnten alte Leute irgendwie nicht lernen. Und das ist Quatsch. Es ist totaler Quatsch. Im Gegenteil, gerade bei alten Leuten wird Internet gerade total modern. Da machen wir mal eine eigene Sendung drüber. Das hat auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, dass alte Leute Zeit haben und dass sie teilweise auch Geld haben. Die werden auch natürlich ein bisschen umworben und so weiter und so fort. Aber da ist einiges in Bewegung und da gibt es eine Menge Leute, die haben noch total intakte Gehirne, auch wenn vielleicht ihre Körper schon ein bisschen die Schnappharzen gespürt haben. Und fangen gerade an, sich da reinzuklingen. Und da bekommt man also schon den Eindruck, dass auch alte Leute sich durchaus sinnvoll da reinarbeiten können. Und insofern können das auch Lehrer. Und reines Alter ist insofern kein Argument so. Sondern das Argument ist natürlich, wenn die irgendwie zu große Klassen haben und zu wenig Zeit, um was zu machen, dann muss man vielleicht tatsächlich mal in Bildung investieren. Sonst fliegt einem irgendwie die ganze Angelegenheit mal in die Ohren.
Das ist richtig. Wobei, das, über was wir uns jetzt die ganze Zeit unterhalten haben, ist ja eigentlich nicht, dass wir mit dem Computer ein bisschen ungern lernen, ein bisschen mit der Maus irgendwie hin und her schieben, sondern wir wollen ja schon ein Stückchen weitergehen. Und bis es dahin kommt, das geht wahrscheinlich noch eine ewig lange Zeit, weil jetzt müssen erstmal alle lernen, wie irgendwie die Maus zu bedienen ist und wie irgendwie...
Naja, aber das kann man ja schon an verschiedenen Dingern aufzäumen. Wenn es da zum Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir wollen Medienkompetenz als wirkliches Fach haben, es gibt genug arbeitslose Pädagogen ohne Ende. Es ist ja nicht so, dass es da nicht genug Nackflugskräfte gibt, sondern es gibt da nicht genug Geld, um Leute einzustellen. So, und da muss man mal was draufwerfen.
Also, schön nicht schlussendlich.
In diesem Sinne, Chaosradio 50 ist zu Ende. Nächsten Monat ist Chaosradio wieder am letzten Mittwoch. Nicht wie heute ausnahmsweise.
Genau, und über das Thema werden wir noch ein bisschen zinieren. Das könnt ihr dann aktuell abrufen auf https www.cccde oder einfach chaosradio.ccc.de Genau, noch Fragen schickt ihr an chaosradio.cccde oder chaosradio.trips.de, oder nicht? Ja, also irgendetwas mit den Verteilern, das müssen wir mal sortieren.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall eine Web-Adresse.
Da gibt es auch irgendwie Mail-Adressen und eine FWK und so Geschichten.
Genau, und ansonsten hören sie an Fritz.
Wir leiten es dann auch weiter.
Herzlichen Dank, dass ihr hier wart. Zum Abschluss noch ein bisschen Musik von Otaku. Was ich vergaß anzukündigen ist natürlich, dass es hier weitergeht, weil nach der Sendung ist vor der Sendung. Und zwar mit dem Night Flight mit Tomaten und Petershoff.
Wer DJ Otaku noch kurz, die Dameanwendung für unser DJ, also wer DJ Otaku hören möchte, kann das morgen Abend im Kato im Kreuzberg auf die Anti-Expo-Party oder am 2.Mini in der C-Base in der Orangenbota 2.